LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AND WE
WELCOME YOU TO THE MAY TWENTY
EIGHTH EDITION OF THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE BEFORE WE GET INTO
THIS MORNING'S HEARING WE HAVE
A PRETTY PACKED DOCKET TODAY
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO COVER SOME
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
HEARING THAT WILL BE HELD NEXT
WEDNESDAY JUNE TWENTY JUNE
THIRD AT NINE THIRTY AM THIS
HEARING SHOULD BE APPROXIMATELY
ONE HOUR AT THAT HEARING WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR TWO BILLS. RE
HERE SENATOR GLAZER BILL WILL
ALSO YOUR BILL FROM SENATOR
BATES FOR TODAY WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE IS ON THE
SAME PAGE WHEN IT COMES TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IS GOING TO BE
THREE WAYS THREE WAYS THAT
FOLKS CAN COMMUNICATE WITH THE
COMMITTEE THIS MORNING WE
WELCOME YOUR COMMENTS VIA PHONE
FIRST AND FOREMOST IF YOU LIKE
TO BE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY VIA
THE PHONE LINE PLEASE DIAL.
844-291-6364 YOU ENTER THE CODE
SIX TWO TWO SIX FIVE FIVE
EIGHT. NEW BE CONNECTED TO AN
OPERATOR THAT PHONE NUMBER AND
CODE IS CURRENTLY ON YOUR
SCREEN WE ALSO CAN BE WELCOMING
TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO THREE AND YOU CAN
PROVIDE VIDEO TESTIMONY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY AGAIN WE'RE GONNA
TAKE THIS SLOW AND STEADY WE'RE
GOING TO ASK FOR A LITTLE BIT
OF PATIENCE BUT WE'RE GONNA GET
THROUGH THIS TOGETHER IN MAKING
SURE THAT ALL VOICES ARE HEARD.
THAT'S ESTABLISH A FORM MR
CANAL CAN YOU PLEASE CALL.
SENATOR MCGUIRE HERE. WHERE
SAID MORLOCK. PRESIDENT WHAT
PRESIDENT SENATOR BELL. SENATOR
HERTZBERG YEAR WHICH BURKE
PRESIDENT SENATOR TADO PRESENT
THE TOTAL PRESENT SENATOR
NIELSEN HASN'T NIELSEN
PRESIDENT SENATOR WIENER. THE
CORE THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
GREEN HOW CAN WE PLEASE MAKE
NOTE THAT THAT SENATOR BAIL IS
AT PRESENT AS WELL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER NOW. ALL RIGHT
PLEASE IN GERMAN WE'D LIKE TO
BE OUR TO GET RIGHT INTO
TODAY'S HEARING- WE'D LIKE TO
BE AT THE START WITH ITEM
NUMBER FOR ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS
SB ELEVEN TWENTY BY THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM ACTIONS ARE
GOING TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
THE PROTEIN IN THIRTY SECONDS
BUT I JUST WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
PRO TEM FOR HER LEADERSHIP. AS
YOU ALL REMEMBER EARLIER THIS
YEAR CENTER ATKINS MADE A
PROMISE MADE A PROMISE TO THE
SENATE INTO MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS BUT SHE WOULD MOVE
A HOUSING PACKAGE BILL FORWARD
A PRODUCTION DEAL THAT WOULD BE
FOCUS ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WE
FOCUS ON PROVIDING HOUSING TO
MILLIONS WHO ARE IN NEED AND
WHAT WE'VE SEEN THROUGH THIS
CORONA VIRUS THE DISPARITIES IN
OUR COME IN OUR ECONOMY IS MORE
THAN EVER AND WE'RE GRATEFUL TO
THE SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
ALL OVER INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP
IN BRINGING TOGETHER A CLOSING
LEAD GROUP. AND A COLLABORATIVE
TO BRING THESE BILLS FOR BETTER
PRO TEM THE FLOOR IS YOURS AND
WE WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY ON SB
ELEVEN TWENTY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
AND- COLLEAGUES FOR. FIVE THE
COURTESY FRANKLY OF LET ME GO
FIRST TODAY AND OF COURSE TO
REPRESENT THE BILL. EARLIER
THIS YEAR THIS IS A SIDE THE
TERENCE. OFF PLAY THAT THERE
WERE BE A HOUSING PACKAGE OF
LEGISLATION THIS YEAR I THINK
WE ALL UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS- PRE CODED WE HAD A
HOUSING CRISIS. IT'S ONLY BEEN
EXACERBATED BECAUSE OF COVRT
NINETEEN. I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN ALONG WITH SENATORS
COVER YEAR ROAD THERE ALSO CAN
SALAS HILL ROTH AND RUBIO. FOR
STEPPING UP TO LEAD THE
DISCUSSION ON THIS ISSUE WITH
ME. SB ELEVEN TWENTY IS PART OF
THE HOUSING PRODUCTION PACKAGE
THAT WAS ANNOUNCED LAST WEEK IT
MAKES MORE HOUSING PRODUCTION
POSSIBLE. EVEN WHILE WE
CONTINUE WORKING THROUGH THE
NEW REALITIES AND ON CERTAIN
TIMES BECAUSE BY THIS PANDEMIC.
AND OF COURSE OUR ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN. IN POSITIONS
CALIFORNIA TO LEAP FORWARD
EXPONENTIALLY ON HOUSING
PRODUCTION AS CIRCUMSTANCES
EASE. I MAKING SURE THE
RECOVERY PROVIDES OPPORTUNITY
AT ALL INCOME LEVELS THE BILL
BEFORE YOU TODAY SB ELEVEN
TWENTY AUTOMATICALLY ALLOWS
PROPERTY OWNERS TO HAVE
DUPLEXES. AND SUBDIVIDE THEIR
PROPERTY IN SINGLE FAMILY HOME
NEIGHBORHOOD STATEWIDE AS LONG
AS EXISTING OR PLANNED
RESIDENCES CONTINUE TO MEET
EXISTING COMMUNITY STANDARDS
AND PROTECTIONS. SB ELEVEN
TWENTY BILLS ON ARE INCREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL APPROACH TO ASSESS
THREE DWELLING UNITS OR A. D.
U.'S. WHICH HAS LED TO A
QUADRUPLING OF APPLICATIONS FOR
THESE UNITS IN MOST METRO AREAS
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS. SB
ELEVEN TWENTY THE PRO TO ALSO
MAKE SMALL SCALE INFILL
DEVELOPMENT MORE ACHIEVABLE IT
HELPS BUILD EQUITY FOR
INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS NOT LARGE
SCALE CORPORATIONS. AND FINALLY
THE BILL RESPECTS THE
PRIORITIES OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN LOCAL LAND USE DECISIONS. IN
ORDER TO ACCESS THE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL HOMEOWNERS MUST
MEET A SPECIFIC LIST OF
QUALIFICATIONS. THAT ENSURE
PROTECTION OF LOCAL ZONING AND
DESIGN STANDARDS HISTORIC
DISTRICTS ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
AND EXISTING TENANTS VULNERABLE
TO DISPLACEMENT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU TO CLARIFY THE ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS
REGARDING- DEFINITIONS. AND I
THANK YOU FOR THAT INFORMATION.
I ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE A
DRAFTING ERROR IN THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THE BILL WHICH ONLY
EXEMPTS SPECIFIC SITES ON
HISTORIC REGISTER I WILL BE
AMENDING THE BILL AT THE NEXT
OPPORTUNITY TO CLARIFY THAT
THIS EXEMPTION EXTENDS TO THE
ENTIRE HISTORIC DISTRICT.
SOMEONE TO MAKE SURE AND TAKE
CARE OF THOSE. ICAL PIECES AT A
BEEN A POINTED OUT. I
UNDERSTAND SOME COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE ARE WORRIED
ABOUT WHAT PHYSICAL CHANGES
THIS MAY BRING TO THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND I KNOW THAT
CHANGE CAN BE SCARY. IT NEVER
BEFORE HAS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND SO CLEARLY A MATTER OF LIFE
AND DEATH OVERCROWDING ON
AFFORDABLE RENTS HOMELESSNESS
THESE WERE ALL SYMPTOMS AS I
SAID EARLIER. OF OUR HOUSING
CRISIS LONG BEFORE COVE IN
NINETEEN. THE ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT I BELIEVE IS TO STEP
IN WHEN THERE IS A CRISIS MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE'S VOICES ARE
HEARD. TO WORK WITH EVERYONE ON
A COMPROMISE AND ULTIMATELY TO
MOVE THE NEEDLE FORWARD THROUGH
LEGISLATION LIKE SB ELEVEN
TWENTY. WITH HAT I AM HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
AND I'M HAPPY. TO BE HERE TODAY
AND I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. JIM THANK YOU AND E ARE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE IN COMMITTEE ADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE COMMITTEE WOULD
LIKE TO BE AT THE START THREE
WAYS OF TESTIMONY. FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE'RE GONNA BEGIN HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO THREE. WE
WELCOME ANY INDIVIDUAL TO
PLEASE STEP UP THE MICROPHONE
TO MY LEFT. IN SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT IN SUPPORT. OF
SB ELEVEN TWENTY. ERNESTINE
KNOWING WHAT RISE WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE GOING TO A REMOTE
HEARING ROOM THAT'S ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE IS NO
ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FOUR TO
PREPARE TO SPEAK. THAT MEANS
WE'RE GONNA BE GOING TO OUR
PHONE LINES. MISTER MODERATOR.
GOODMORNING AGAIN SIR WE'RE
GOING TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN TWENTY CAN
YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP. ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN TWENTY.
WE'LL TAKE A QUICK PASS. MISTER
CHAIR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. THANK YOU
FOR COULD PLEASE- ELEVATOR
BALLING THE BIT FOR THE
MODERATORS SO WE CAN HERE AND
IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD
BE APPRECIATED. IT'S A
MODERATOR ON TO BE COMING BACK
TO YOU MISTER MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE PREPARED TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN TWENTY.
WE DO LINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GOOD MORNING
HEARING COMMITTEE MORNING.
MORNING I DID THE DAILY GABBARD
BUT THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS AND WE ARE INCOME
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOUR TESTIMONY MISTER
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BLIND TWENTY FIVE GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING- JERRY MEMBERS-
ANOTHER NOT LIKE HOW PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS YOU'RE DRUNK WITH
PORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH A GROUP OF YOUR TESTIMONY.
WE'RE GONNA BE GOING TO OUR
NEXT CALLER MISTER MODERATOR.
LINE THIRTY SEVEN MORNING. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ROBERT NAIL
REPRESENTING FEELS THAT AND
COMPANY AN ORANGE COUNTY AND
BUSINESS STRONGLY SUPPORT OF
THE CALIFORNIA U. M. B. AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE PRO TEMAS
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH. MISTER
MODERATOR COMING BACK TO YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE EIGHT
SEE GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING
MR HERE A GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STILL DO
FERRARI ON BEHALF OF FACEBOOK
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOUR TESTIMONY MISTER MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. LINE FORTY ONE
GOOD MORNING. NINE FORTY ONE
GOOD MORNING HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ON A. GOOD MORNING
SHARED MEMBERS COMMITTEE ADAM
RIGHTLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MISTER MODERATOR HOW MANY
FOLKS WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE.
THREE THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE NINETEEN
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING LINE
NINETEEN. SORRY ABOUT THAT GOOD
MORNING MR SURE NUMBERS WEREN'T
ABLE AND SHARE REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE MR MODERATOR.
LINE FOURTEEN. GOOD MORNING
TRACY RYAN ON BEHALF THE URBAN
COUNTY THAT CALIFORNIA CALPERS
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
IN THE WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTS
THE CALIFORNIA- BUT WE DO NOT
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON AT
ELEVEN TWENTY ON THE KEY
ELEMENTS OF THE SENATE HOUSING
PRODUCTION PACKAGE THOUGH ALIGN
WITH OUR GOALS- OF THAT COUNTY
SHARE IN PROVIDING OPTIONS FOR
GENTLE INCREASES AND DENSITY
WHAT CAN BUILT OUT RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOOD- WE'VE IDENTIFIED
TECHNICAL ISSUES AND SHARE THEM
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE WE HAVE
TO ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS TO
ENSURE THE BILL DOESN'T AND IT
BURDEN LANE. WITHOUT AN
UNMITIGATED IMPACT AND
DIFFICULTY IMPLEMENTING THAT
THE LOT LIQUOR VISIONS IN THE
UNINCORPORATED AN
UNINCORPORATED AREAS DUE TO
THEIR ABILITY AND LIMITED
INFRASTRUCTURE WE LOOK FORWARD
TO GETTING OUR WORK WITH YOU
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
HOW CAN PRODUCTION WORKERS TO
REFINANCE PROPOSAL SO AT THE
DIRECT EDITION ALL
UNINCORPORATED HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AREAS BEST SUITED
FOR CULMINATING IN SOME CREDIT
THANK YOU. PLEASE. RYAN WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. IT'S
MODERATOR THIS TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE FORTY TWO.
EARNING GOOD MORNING COULD MEET
THE ENEMY HAPPENED BRIDGE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE
FORTY THREE GOOD MORNING. THIS
MORNING THE THIRTY MARKET NOW
THAT HAPPENED A VERY HELPFUL
AND- THANK YOU SO MUCH. MISTER
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. LINE
FORTY FOUR GOOD MORNING THIS IS
GREATER GOOD MORNING IT'S A
GREAT HONOR ON BEHALF OF
CARPENTER HERE IS FOR SCHNEIDER
ELECTRIC NORTH AMERICAN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE MR MODERATOR.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE SOMEBODY-
QUEUING UP RIGHT NOW WILL HAVE
THEM IN JUST A MOMENT THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A MATTER. THIS TAKE
A QUICK MOMENT. ONE FORTY SIX
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING
COREY SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
BAY AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY
COALITION THE COR TO SB ABOUT
THE NEW TWENTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER SMITH MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN TWENTY. WE DO WE ARE NOW
A GOING TO GO TO THE LINE OF
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING
NUMBER ONE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU THIS IS A
PHILADELPHIA CRANK CALLING ON
BEHALF OF. THE LOOK ON VALUE AT
HOME IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. MISTER
MODERATOR HOW MANY FOLKS TO
HAVE IN THE QUEUE. THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE MISTER
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MODERATOR MISTER MODERATOR WE
ARE NOW GOING TO BE COMING BACK
TO THE HEARING ROOM TO BE A
CHECKING WITH ANY OPPOSITION
WE'RE GONNA START HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. HERE IN FORTY TWO
OR THREE IS THERE ANYONE WHO'D
LIKE TO RISE IN OPPOSITION SB
ELEVEN TWENTY PLEASE STEP FOR
THE MIKE NOW. HEARING SEEN NO
ONE WE ARE NOW GOING TO BE
GOING TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY WERE
TOLD THAT THERE IS O ONE. IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. ORGAN
REMEMBER BACK HERE IN ASK THE
MODERATOR TO PLEASE Q. PLEASE
Q. ANY INDIVIDUAL. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OF SB ELEVEN TWENTY
PLEASE DO THAT NOW MISTER
MODERATOR. YES AND IS DIRECTED
BY THE CHAIR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ONE THAN ZERO. WE'RE
NOT LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO WERE
IN OPPOSITION AND SB ELEVEN
TWENTY. MISTER MODERATOR ON AND
COME BACK TO YOU SIR HOW MANY
FOLKS WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE.
THERE IS NO ONE. ALL RIGHT IT'S
DO A LAST CALL LAST CALL FOR
THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED TO SB
ELEVEN TWENTY CAN YOU PLEASE DO
A LAST CALL MISTER MODERATOR.
ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
PRIEST PLUS ONE THE NEW ZERO.
AGAIN THERE IS NO ONE MISTER
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MODERATOR. MISTER MOORE
LARGEST CITIES CAN BE CALLING
AND SO GOOD TIMES ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE LET'S HAVE SOME
DISCUSSION ANY CONVERSATION
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME. YES
SENATOR WIENER GOOD MORNING SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN-
PROUD TO BE A JOINT AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL AND ALL. I WANTED TO
US REALLY THANK. THE PRO TEM
FOR NOT JUSTICE BUILD BUT FOR-
DOING WHAT SHE SAID SHE WASGOING TO DO BACK IN JANUARY
SHE- SAID VERY FIRMLY WE ARE
GOING TO DO PRODUCTION THIS
YEAR. AND HONESTLY WHEN THE
PANDEMIC HIT- A LOT OF PEOPLE
SAID TO ME IT'S NEVER GOING TO
HAPPEN NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN-
YOU KNOW WE NEED THE- PEOPLE
ORGAN ONLY FOCUS. ON THE
PANDEMIC. I TOLD THEM I DON'T
THINK THAT WAS THE CASE-
BECAUSE WE CAN WALK AND CHEW
GUM AT THE SAME TIME AND WHAT
WE'RE DOING WITH THIS TERRIBLE
HEALTH EMERGENCY AND ECONOMIC
EMERGENCY. WE DO HAVE TO FOCUS
ON SOME OF THE COREISSUES THAT
ARE THREATENING THE FUTURE OF
OUR STATE BECAUSE- THE PANDEMIC
IS GOING TO AND THE QUESTION IS
ARE WE GOING TO THEN BE EVEN
FURTHER BEHIND. ON HOUSING- AND
SO. THIS IS A- AND THIS IN
PARTICULAR THIS BILL. IS A
REALLY SMART APPROACH BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE GOING TO
BE ECONOMIC IMPACTS ON THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY- AND YOU
KNOW HIGH I HOPE THEIR MINIMIZE%
BUT- FROM THE LARGE SCALE
CONSTRUCTION. IN PARTICULAR AND
FINANCING THERE COULD BE SOME
DELAYS- BUT I MEAN WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS LATER TOUCHY
SMALLER PROJECTS. THE DUPLEX IN
HERE BECAUSE OF A LOT SPLIT ITS
TWO DUPLEXES POTENTIALLY ON A-
LOT THAT IS LARGE ENOUGH. THESE
ARE MUCH LOWER COST WAYS OF
ADDING HOUSING. THIS IS HOUSING
THAT CAN BE ADDED EVEN DURING
AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. IT IS
LATER TOUCH. IN TERMS OF
CHANGES PHYSICALLY. IN A
COMMUNITY I THINK IT STRIKES A
REALLY STRONG BALANCE- THE-
SOME OF THE PROVISIONS- IN IN
THE BILL AROUND DEMOLITION
OTHERWISE I THINK ALSO STRIKE.
A REALLY STRONG BALANCE OF THIS
IS A REALLY. SOLID SOLID BILL
THAT OVER TIME. WILL RESULT IN
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF NEW
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA. A VERY
HUMAN SCALE- THE DOESN'T YOU
KNOW CHANGE THE HEIGHT LIMITS
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT AND- FOR
SOME OF US TO- THING TYPE CAN
BE A GOOD THING- YOU KNOW WE
WANT TO. STRIKE A BALANCE AND
EVEN IN SB FIFTY WE OFTEN
DEFERRED. TO LOCAL HEIGHT
LIMITS IN THIS BILL DOES THAT
NOTS INAPPROPRIATE. THINGS WELL
AS LOCAL DESIGN STANDARDS SO.
ON THIS IS A REALLY STRONG BILL
AND I'M PROUD TO BE A JOINT
AUTHOR AND I WANT TO THANK. THE
PRO TEMPORE HER LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER WIENER
BREAK. THIS TO THE JURY LEADER
MR HERTZBERG. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE A COUPLE OF THOUGHTS
BECAUSE I LIVE IN IN REPRESENT
COMMUNITIES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WHERE THE
UNDERLYING OF FOUNDATION OF
THIS BILL HAS WORKED
BRILLIANTLY. I THINK IN THE
COMMUNITIES I REPRESENT AS WELL
OVER FIVE THOUSAND A TO USEAS
WE- IN THE LOS ANGELES
DELEGATION WHICH IS ORGANIZED
REALLY WELL NOW AND WE'VE HAD
SERIES OF MEETINGS AND SERIES
OF MEETINGS WITH EXPERTS ON
HOUSING. WHAT'S THE PROBLEM
WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE HOW DO WE
GET THERE HOW DO WE DO QUICKLY.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO
BE ABLE TO JUST WRITE CHECKS
FOR EVERYTHING. AND WHAT THIS
POLICY DOES AND YOU KNOW I ABLE
FIVE THOUSAND EIGHTY USE. IN
THE COMMUNITIES THAT I
REPRESENT HE IS A- YOU BEING
ABLE TO GET HOUSING FAST WHICH
IS REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE A
LOT OF THIS STUFF ABOUT HOUSING
IS OLD PERMITS IN YEARS AND
TIME. TO IT'S BETWEEN THE
COMMITTEES I REPRESENT BETWEEN
FORTY AND A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER DOOR. RATHER THAN
WE'RE SPENDING IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY JUST ON GOVERNMENT
SUBSIDIES HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND. SO YOU GET IT QUICK.
YOU PUT THE COMMUNITY TO WORK.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THAT LAST
YEAR THE YEAR BEFORE I CAN'T
RECALL. THE NORTHEAST SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY WHICH IS MARK
MARK MOSTLY LATINO APPLIED FOR
A TRANSFORMATIONAL GRANT FOR
THIS STRATEGIC OF COUNSEL. AND
PART OF THAT EFFORT WAS YOU HAD
MAKE SHOWING THAT YOU HAD A
HOUSING COMPONENT AND THE GROUP
ARE LED BY BECOMING THE
BEAUTIFUL BASICALLY INSTEAD OF
SAYING WELL WE'RE GONNA WAIT
FIVE YEARS TO BUILD BUT TO
BUILD BUILDINGS THEIR ENTIRE
TRANSFORMATIONAL PLAN SENATE
AROUND THE NOTION OF EIGHTY
USE. THAT'S WHAT THEY DID THAT
WAS THEIR PLAN AND IT WAS
ACCEPTED AND WE GOT TWENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS AND
THAT'S THE FOCUS IS TOO FEW
MARY THIS WITH WHAT WITH WHAT
WE'VE ALREADY DONE WAS AN
ACCOUNT SKI CENTERS SKINNER MR
TANG AND THE LIKE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THIS IS REALLY DOES
IN A VERY ELEGANT WAY- DEAL
WITH THE ISSUE. GET UNITS AND
IS WERE FACING THESE FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES IT'S A WAY TO PUT
PUT UNITS UP WITHOUT A DELAY BE
GETTING PEOPLE TO WORK. AND SHE
WITHOUT HUGE GOVERNMENTAL
SUBSIDIES BECAUSE I'M TELLING
YOU- YOU KNOW ON THE GROUND
IT'S NOT JUST POLICY IT'S
HAPPENING AT A BREAKNECK SPEED
I HAVE BEEN ON THE PHONE OVER
THE LAST NUMBER OF WEEKS WITH
PROBABLY MORE THAN A DOZEN.
CONTRACTORS JUST SHE WAS LIKE
HOW DOES IT WORK WHAT'S
HAPPENING ASSIST USES PRACTICAL
AND BY EVERY SINGLE ONE TO A
PERSON WHO'S ACTUALLY ON THE
GROUND DOING THIS WORK SAID
FANTASTIC GREAT POLICY IT WILL
BE VERY VERY IMPORTANT TO WITH
THAT. I THANK YOU FOR THIS HARD
WORK I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND VERY PRACTICAL
AND NECESSARY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS THE MAJORITY LEADER WE
LIKE TO BE TO DO A LAST CALL
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
THIS COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WILL BE THE MOTION FOR BY
CENTER WIENER A MAN FROM TIM
THIS BILL IS SMART AND FOCUSED
ON INFILL DEVELOPMENT LED BY
HOMEOWNERS. AND I JUST WANNA.
TAKE ONE LAST TIME TO SAY.
CENTER WIENER NOSES SENT
INSTANCES IT IS NOT EASY NOT
EASY TO DO HOUSING LEGISLATION.
AND THE REASON WHY WE'RE HERE
TODAY LOOKING AT THIS BILL BY
THE PRO TEM IS BECAUSE SHE'S A
PERSON OVER WORD. SHE'S
COLLABORATIVE SHE MEETS WITH
EVERYONE AND IT'S BEEN
INCREDIBLY CLEAR RESERVATION
AND JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR MAKING A DIFFERENCE FOR AND
TURNED OVER TO THE PRO TEMPORE
CLOSING COMMENTS MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU I KNOW YOU
HAVE A LOT BEFORE YOU TODAY I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE MY
COLLEAGUES ARE. AND CERTAINLY
MISTER BELL WHO HAS A LONG
HISTORY ALSO BUT WE WOULDN'T BE
HERE TODAY WITHOUT PIECES OF
LEGISLATION THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
FORWARD BY. SENATOR BAIL IN THE
PAST SENATOR WINNER OF COURSE.
WHO GAVE US THE BAND WITH TO
MOVE FURTHER IN AND CERTAINLY
THE EIGHTY YOU BILL. AND BILLS
BY NUMEROUS MEMBERS INCLUDING
OUR OWN SENATOR WE CASKEY THOSE
HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLE MOVEMENTS
FORWARD AND I DON'T THINK WE
WOULD BE HERE TODAY. WITH THE
POSSIBILITY OF DOING. THIS BILL
AND OTHER BILLS TO CALM WITHOUT
THEIR INCREDIBLE WORK. IT TAKES
A LOT OF WORK. I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE SPEAKERS TODAY THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WEIGHED IN
FOR THEIR INPUT WE STILL WILL
BE WORKING WITH THE COUNTIES
MISS RYAN I HEARD YOU I KNOW
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE.
FOLLOWING UP. I COME OUT OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT I WAS A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER BEFORE THAT I
WAS A STAFF MEMBER I'VE BEEN TO
MORE COMMUNITY PLANNING
COMMITTEES. HOUR UPON HOUR UPON
HOUR I GREATLY RESPECT THAT
PROCESS. THIS IS A BALANCE OF
PUSHING US TO THINK ABOUT HOW
TO HELP OUR COMMUNITIES PROVIDE
HOUSING. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN A WAY THAT IS
APPROPRIATE THAT IS BALANCED.
AND I'M PROUD OF THE WORK OF MY
COLLEAGUES. THAT GOT US HERE
TODAY. MY NAME MAYBE THE TOP
NAME ON THE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION BUT I'M PRETTY
CLEAR. THIS IS BEEN A VERY
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS WITH A
LOT OF INPUT. AND SO I THANK
ALL OF MY **** WITH YEAH. ARE
ASK FOR AND I'VE- AND- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
MAYOR PRO TEM MISTER COLONEL
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS BY SENATOR WITH
SERRANO. REQUIRE LARA. SAYS
MORLOCK. MOORLACH HI SENATOR
BILL RIGHT NOW BY SENATOR HER
FIGHT HERTZBERG HI SENATOR HI
THE TITLE ALRIGHT SENATOR.
BILLS IN OUR SENATOR WIENER
WIENER HI. IT'S A SEVEN ZERO
VOTE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THAT
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE THANK YOU SO MUCH AND FROM
TEN. HAVE A GOOD REST OF THE
DAY. MEMBERS IT WE'RE GONNA BE
GOING TO SENATOR GLAZERS
SHORTLY BUT BEFORE WE DO WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
WISH A HAPPY BIRTHDAY. IT WAS
CALLING HER NAILS THIRTY NINTH
BIRTHDAY OVER THE AND WE WANT
TO WISH HIM A HAPPY BIRTHDAY
AND- ANYTHING TO DO YOU LIKE TO
GET A REPORT AND MISTER NOW
FROM THE BIRTHDAY CELEBRATION.
A YOUR YOU'RE VERY KIND MAN AND
I'M STILL IN DURING MY THIRTIES
MISTER NOW HAD IT NOT ONE NOT
TWO BUT THREE DIFFERENT
BIRTHDAY DESSERTS OVER THE
WEEKEND WHICH WAS PRETTY
AMAZING SO. HAPPY BIRTHDAY
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE HARD WORK
MISTER NOW. ALRIGHT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO GO TO
ITEM NUMBER THREE ITEM NUMBER
THREE IS SB TEN FORTY NINE THIS
IS FOCUSING. ON LOCAL
ORDINANCES AND SHORT TERM
RENTALS SENATOR GLACIER IS
COMING TO US. LIVE FROM THE
GREAT CITY OF ORINDA- AND WE DO
HAVE CUED UP RIGHT NOW VICE
MAYOR WORSE FROM THE CITY
ARANDA TO TESTIFY. ON THE PHONE
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO LET'S TURN
IT OVER TO CENTER GLAZER ON SB
TEN FORTY NINE SENATOR. I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR FULL
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL I'M- HAPPY TO.
CHECK IT'S THAT ARE. ALICE'S
OUT MEN AND SAYS TEN NINE BUT
AUTHORIZES SAY OR CAL TO IMPOSE
A FINE UP TO FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER VIOLATION OF A
SHORT TERM RENTAL ORDINANCE
CURRENTLY SHORT TERM RENTAL
SUCH AS AIRBNB HOMEAWAY B. R.
B. L. HAVE BECOME INCREASINGLY
POPULAR AIRBNB ALONG WITH SHORT
TERM RENTALS IN EIGHTY ONE
THOUSAND CITIES. UNDER NINETY
ONE COUNTRIES SO SHORT TERM
RENTALS OFFER A WAY TO IMPROVE
TOURISM AND EARN OWNERS EXTRA
MONEY THERE HAVE BEEN SOME BAD
ACTORS AND THEY HAVE USE THAT
PLATFORM HOST LARGE PARTIES
LARGE GATHERINGS HAVE MADE SOME
SHORT TERM RENTAL PROPERTIES
THE SITE OF UNDER AGE DRINKING
BRAWLS AND NOISE COMPLAINTS.
AND MOST TRAGICALLY LAST YEAR.
IT HOMETOWN OF ORINDA AT A
PARTY YEAH AIRBNB RENTAL FIVE
PEOPLE WERE KILLED. NOW THE
PROBLEM IS THAT MANY OF THESE
HOMES GET RANCID FOR HUGE PRICE
TAGS THOUSAND A NIGHT TWO
THOUSAND THREE THOUSAND A
NIGHT. AND IN THESE INSTANCES.
A FINE OF UP TO A THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER VIOLATION IS NOT
ENOUGH IN MY OPINION TO DO TO
DETER BAD ACTORS I'M TRYING TO
MAKE A QUICK PROFIT. THIS BILL
WILL GIVE TOOLS TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES- THAT CAN DETER PEOPLE
FROM TAKING ADVANTAGE OF SHORT
TERM RENTALS TO HOST
DESTRUCTIVE AN UNSAFE. HOUSE
PARTIES I THIS IS AN ADDITIONAL
TOOL THAT I THINK THE CITIES
AND COUNTIES WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
A PLEASE THAT WE HAVE SUPPORT
FROM. MANY THOSE ENTITIES FOR
THIS LEGISLATION AND WHAT
BETTER RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR GLACIER WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY LEADERSHIP
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WE'D
LIKE TO BETTER START WITH
TESTIMONY TESTIMONY ON THE
PHONE. BUT WE DO HAVE ANY WORSE
THE VICE MAYOR FROM THE CITY OF
ORINDA ON THE LINE. THAT
INVITES MARY WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES WE'LL GIVE YOU A THIRTY
SECOND PROMPT. MADAM VICE MAYOR
OF THE FLOOR IS YOURS THREE
MINUTES. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
DEAR CHAIR MCGUIRE AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- I'M AT WORDS
VICE MAYOR VERANDA AND I WANT
TO THANK. TARA REID WE'RE GOING
TO CHECK IN WITH OUR
TELECONFERENCE FOR WRITER THIS
GIVE US A QUICK MOMENT. OKAY
GREAT- YOUR BACK OKAY THEN NICE
MAYORS BACK MINIMIZE MAYOR WE
LOST YOU. THERE FOR ABOUT
TWENTY SECONDS AMENDED VICE
MAYOR IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND WE
APOLOGIZE WOULD YOU MIND
STARTING YOUR STATEMENT OVER WE
LOST IT FOR ABOUT TWENTY
SECONDS. SENATOR I'D BE VERY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DEAR DEAR
MCGUIRE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M AMY WORDS VICE
MAYOR VERANDA AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL CAN
FORTY NINE THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE CITIES WITH AN
IMPORTANT TOOL IN MANAGING
SHORT TERM RENTALS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL TO SENATOR GLAZERS.
FOR SPONSORING THIS LEGISLATION.
YOU WILL RECALL THE TRAGIC
MURDERS ON HALLOWEEN NIGHT IN A
READ THAT THAT OCCURRED AND
ILLEGAL GATHERING AT A SHORT
TERM RENTAL. THIS UNSPEAKABLE
TRAGEDY WITH DEVASTATING TO THE
FAMILIES OF THE VICTIMS AND TO
OUR COMMUNITY. WHEN HORT TERM
RENTAL HOUSING PLATFORMS CAME
INTO EXISTENCE MANY CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA CHOSE TO PAY ON THEM
COMPLETELY SH IN A WRITTEN A WE
CHOSE A MORE MODERN APPROACH TO
PERMIT. AND A DOCTOR AN
ORDINANCE CLEARLY OUTLINED THE
RULES. THAT INCLUDED NO RENTALS
FOR LARGE PARTIES AND THE
REQUIREMENT THAT SHORT TERM
RENTALS REGISTER THEIR
PROPERTY. SHOULD BE ADOPTION OF
OUR ORDINANCE STAFF HAS WORKED
WITH PROPERTY OWNERS AND
NEIGHBORS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
AND COMPLAINTS. THIS REQUIRES
EXTENSIVE STAFF RESOURCES BUT
IT ALSO REQUIRES THE
ADMINISTRATIVE TOOLS TO DO
EFFECTIVE ENFORCEMENT.
FOLLOWING THE HALLOWEEN TRAGEDY
WE FURTHER STRENGTHEN OUR
ORDINANCE TO RESTRICT RENTALS
TO HOSTED RENTALS WITH TWO
NIGHT MINIMUM. HOWEVER THE
GREATEST CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE
IS THE ABILITY TO ENFORCE THE
RULES IN THE FACE OF SERIOUS
VIOLATIONS. THE COMPLIANCE
SHORT TERM RENTAL PROPERTIES
WITH LOCAL ZONING ORDINANCES IS
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF BOTH. THE
PROPERTY OWNER AND THE SHORT
TERM RENTAL PLATFORMS. HAVING
AN ADEQUATE FINE STRUCTURE IS
THE ONLY WAY WE WILL BE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY MANAGE AND ENFORCE.
THESE REASONABLE OREGON SAYS. I
RENDER LIKE MANY CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA IS THE GENERAL LAW
CITY AND THE STATE LEGISLATURE
SETS THE STATUTORY LIMIT FOR
FIVE. THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE A
MUCH NEEDED TOOL FOR CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA TO ENFORCE THEIR
SHORT TERM RENTAL ORDINANCES.
AND AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES- CONSIDERATION OF
OUR TESTIMONY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT SHORT
TERM RENTAL BILL AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE VICE MAYOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY IN YOUR
LEADERSHIP LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT WE ASKING
POTTERY WE'RE GONNA AT THE
MODERATOR ON THE LINE TO PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK SUPPORT OF
SB TEN. A NINE MISTER- CAN YOU
PLEASE GIVE WHAT THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FORTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. YES
LATEST GOVERNMENT THIS TIME IF
YOU WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
WE DO HAVE A SOME PARTICIPANTS
WHO WERE QUEUING UP RIGHT NOW
JUST A MOMENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS MODERATOR YOU LET US KNOW
WHEN YOU'RE READY TO GO. BLIND
FIFTY SEVEN MONNING I JUST
OPENED. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TOWN CALLED
LORD AFTER CALIFORNIA HOTEL
LODGING ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL CALDWELL WE
ALWAYS LOVE HEARING FROM YOU
THANK YOU SOMUCH SIR BACK TO
YOU MISTER MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD MORNING.
HI GOOD MORNING SURE YOU MANY
MEMBERS MICHELLE RANTS ON THE
HOUSE OF EXPEDIA GROUP AND THE
COURT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE HAVE A CALLER QUEUING UP AT
THIS MOMENT JUST ANOTHER MOMENT
PLEASE GOOD. SO WITH THAT. ONE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD MORNING. PITCH GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR NUMBER SO
THE INSULATION ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISHA. LATER HOW MANY FOLKS WE
HAVE IN THE QUEUE. THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE ALL RIGHT WE DO A LAST
CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF TEN FORTY NINE IT'S
A MODERATOR. AND AGAIN LATEST
GERMAN PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN
ZERO PRESS ONE AND ZERO. HOW WE
LOOKING MISTER MODERATOR. THERE
IS NO ONE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A MODERATOR. WE ARE
NOW GOING TO TURN OVER HERE TO
IN PERSON TESTIMONY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD AND
MICROPHONE IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OF TEN FORTY NINE. HEARING SEEN
NO ONE ARE NOW GOING TO GO TO
OUR ROOM AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE PREPARED TO TESTIFY IN.
COURT I HAVE A SEAT IN FORTY
NINE IN OUR VIDEO ROOM IN
TWENTY FORTY. ARE NOW GOING TO
BE TURNING IT OVER TO THOSE WHO
MAY BE OPPOSE MISTER MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE TO UP ALL OF
THOSE WHO ARE OF. ALL THOSE
PLEASE SB TEN FORTY NINE NOW. I
WANT TO GET PLEASE ENTER MEANT
TO SPEAK. FOR OPPOSED. PLEASE
PRESS ONE BEEN ZERO. ALL RIGHT
MISTER MODERATOR HOW WE LOOK IN
ON THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED.
THERE IS NO ONE ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER MODERATOR
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ASKING
FOR IN PERSON TESTIMONY FOR
ANYONE WHO'S IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE OPPOSITION TO TEN
FORTY NINE. SEE NO ONE WE'RE
NOT GONNA GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THERE IS NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THIS IS TRAGEDY
HERE- WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. AND OPEN IT UP
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR MOTION PLEASE. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR TANTO
IT THAT MOTION IS TO DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE FLOOR- IN OF
COURSE CENTER GLAZIER JUST
WANNA CONFIRM YOUR TAKING THOSE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PLEASE. YES
SIR HAPPY TO TAKE DOZEN MEMBERS
OF THANK YOU TO YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR THEIR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER GLAZER OF CLOSING
COMMENT PLEASE. WE SHOULD THE
CONSIDERATION AND WHICH
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT
OUT. AGAIN CENTER GLAZER THANKS
SO MUCH FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL THE MIGHT
VICE MAYOR FROM THE CITY AROUND
AND BEING WITH THIS. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS IS AMENDED TO THE
FLOOR. MR NOW ROLL CALL PLEASE.
SENATOR MCGUIRE HIGH. WIRE
ARTIST SENATOR MORLOCK NOTE.
BERLOCQ KNOWS SENATOR BILL.
BILL HI SENATOR HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HI SENATOR HURTADO HI
RICARDO BY SENATOR NIELSEN HI
NIELSEN HI SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER FIVE SIX TWO ONE AT THE
SIX ONE VOTE SIX ONE VOTE WE
ARE GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLE THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER GLAZER AND WE'LL BE
TALKING TO YOU SOON SIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MASON GENERAL
MIDI WERE NOW GOING TO BE
JUMPING BACK TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
ITEM. SENATOR SKINNER CENTER
SKINNER IS HERE TODAY. WE
WELCOME OR TO COMMITTEE WERE
NEVER COME UP TO THE PODIUM.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WERE
GOING TO HAVE HER LEAD WITNESS
TESTIFYING IN PERSON TODAY-
THAT'S GOING TO BE. TERRY
BERNARD. FROM S. YEAH YOU.
WITHIN ARE GONNA TAKING TO
INDIVIDUALS ON THE PHONE WHO
WILL BE OPPOSE. THAT'S GOING TO
BE DUST AND WEATHER BE. AS WELL
AS NIKKI DEAL BAY. SO WE'RE
GONNA AND QUEUE UP DESTIN IN
NIKKI. SO THAT THEY ARE
PREPARED. TO BE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION. AT WITHOUT FURTHER
DO THOUGH WE'RE GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO SENATOR SKINNER TO
PRESENT. SB NINE SEVENTY TWO
GOOD MORNING MA'AM IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AND- I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS.
AND ALL OPEN READ IT SB NINE
SEVEN TWO WILL ALIGN CALIFORNIA
WHICH STATES LIKE FLORIDA
INDIANA MINNESOTA MISSISSIPPI
NEBRASKA OKLAHOMA IN SOME SEVEN
OTHERS THAT REQUIRED
DISCLOSURE. BY LARGE
CORPORATIONS OF THE STATE TAX
CREDITS TAKEN BY THOSE ENTITIES
AND THE AMOUNT OF STATE TAXES
PAID THIS PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
INFORMATION GIVES THE
POLICYMAKERS AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS TO DATA. ON THEIR TAX
POLICIES THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
EVALUATE TAX POLICY. CALIFORNIA
POLICY MAKERS AND THE PUBLIC DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THIS DATA SO
WHILE WE CAN GET. FROM OUR- F.
T. B. WERE CONTROLLERS OFFICE
THE TOTAL FOR EXAMPLE OF
REVENUE THAT WE RECEIVE SKEWS
ME MY MASK KEEPS FALLING OFF MY
NOSE. THE TOTAL REVENUE THAT WE
RECEIVE SAY FROM CORPORATE
INCOME TAXES WHICH ARE I WILL
POINT OUT I'M DIVERTING A
LITTLE BIT BUT- BY TODAY.
CORPORATE INCOME TAX ONLY
REFLECTS. 9% OF OUR TOTAL
GENERAL FUND REVENUES IN THE
PAST IT WAS UP 217% AND SO THIS
IS AT A TIME WHEN CLARA
CALIFORNIA IS CRITICIZED FOR
HER FOR HAVING VERY VOLATILE%
CELL STATE REVENUES AND BEING
RELIANCE PRIMARILY ON
INDIVIDUAL INCOME TAX AND YET
OUR REVENUE IN TOTAL FROM
CORPORATE TAXES IS A VERY LOW
PERCENT OF OUR GENERAL FUND.
AND WE CAN'T EVEN ANALYZE
WHETHER THOSE CORPORATIONS
WHICH TODAY ARE. FIVE MAYBE NOT
EXACTLY TODAY BUT IN GENERAL
RECORDING RECORD PROFITS WHAT
THEY ARE PROVIDING TO US AND SO
WHEN WE DEBATE TAX POLCY. WE
HAVE VERY LITTLE INFORMATION TO
REALLY INFORM ANY TYPES OF
DECISIONS NOW OPTIMALLY I THINK
SUCH A DATABASE THAT SB NINE
SEVEN TWO IS ESTABLISHING
SHOULD INCLUDE. THE DATA ON THE
INDIVIDUAL TAX BREAKS IN OTHER
WORDS DOESCORPORATE TAX TAKE
WATERS IT DOES IT TAKE YOU KNOW
WHAT THE WHOLE VARIETY OF THEM
AND WE HAVE MANY MANY MANY MANY
MANY. BUT NO THIS IS A VERY
SIMPLE DATABASE IT IS PURELY
THOSE CORPORATIONS WITH GROCERY
BEATS FIVE BILLION OR MORE. WHO
WOULD INFORM US OF THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF STATE TAXES PAID AND
THE TOTAL AMOUNT THE VALUE OF
STATE TAX CREDITS. EVENTUALLY
WE SHOULD HAVE MORE DATA BUT
GIVEN. THE TYPE OF. GIVEN TAT
WE ARE OUR REVENUES ARE DOWN WE
DO NOT WANT TO ADD A LOT OF
COST TO OUR DEPARTMENTS IN
TRYING TO GATHER SUCH DATA OR
SYMBOL SUCH A DATABASE. SO I
WENT WITH THE SIMPLEST.
INITIALLY NOW JUST AS CONTRAST
I GIVE YOU SOME STATE
INFORMATION FEDERALLY ALL
PUBLICLY TRADED CORPORATIONS NO
NOTE I SAID THAT THIS BILL
COVERS. CORPORATIONS WITH GROSS
RECEIPTS OF FIVE BILLION OR
MORE IT IS NOT BLUE IT IS NOT
LIMITED TO PUBLICLY TRADED HOW
EVER. THE MATURITY AND I MEAN
THE VAST MAJORITY OVER 95% OF
THE CORPORATIONS THAT WOULD
FALL UNDER THIS FIVE BILLION OR
HIGHER GROSS RECEIPTS ARE
PUBLICLY TRADED THERE ARE VERY
FEW COURT. NOW MY CONTRAST IS
THAT THERE'S NATIONAL
LEGISLATION THAT REQUIRES ALL
PUBLICLY TRADED CORP COMPANIES
REGARDLESS OF SIZE. TO DISCLOSE
TO THE SECURITIES EXCHANGE
COMMISSION THE AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL TO THE PAY THE TAX
DEDUCTIONS TAKEN THEIR CEO PAY
THEIR EMPLOYEE MEETING MEDIAN
EMPLOYEE PAY AND THAT'S A
RATHER INFO. WE HAVE THAT
ACCESS FEDERALLY WE JUST DON'T
HAVE THAT DATA IN CALIFORNIA IN
TERMS OF ABILITY TO HAVE PUBLIC
ACCESS- SO WITH THAT BY WILL
TURN TO. MY A PRIMARY WITNESS
WHICH IS TERRY BRENNAN FROM
SGI. THANK YOU SO MUCH A MATTER
SENATOR WE WELCOME SIR BERNARD
TO IT TO THE COMMITTEE TERRY
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES SO GIVE
YOU THIRTY SECOND PROMPT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU- MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JERRY BROWN
AND ON BEHALF SCA YOU
CALIFORNIA. PROUD TO SPONSOR
PIECE OF LEGISLATION- AT THE
STANDARD IN A FABULOUS. JOB OF
A- RENTING A IT'S A SIMPLE
BUILT TO ALLOW CAL. HAVE THE
SAME TOOL THAT THE FEDERAL. HAS
IN ASSESSING- WHERE TAX CREDITS
GO GET THEM AND WHETHER THEY'RE
GETTING THE DESIRED EFFECT- I
WILL SAY THE OPPOSITION HAS
SAID THIS VIOLATES THE- TAX
PAYER PRIVACY ACT WE ARE ASKING
FOR. TWO DATA POINTS NOT
RELEASING YOUR ENTIRE TAX
RETURN NO TRADE SECRETS. JUST
TO DATA POINT- IN ADDITION TO
THAT NOTHING IN THIS BILL AS-
WELL. DESCRIBED IN THE-
ANALYSIS BY THE BIRTHDAY BOY
HERE- NOTHING IN THIS BILL
CHANGES A TAX CREDIT LOWERS A
TAX CREDIT ELIMINATES TAX
CREDIT. IT DOESN'T CHANGE YOUR
ABILITY TO PAY YOUR FAIR LEVEL
OF TAXES TO MATTER WHAT. AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. SO
MUCH SIR WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WOULD TAKE ME TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
WHO'D LIKE TO BETTER TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVENTY TWO. ROOM. FORTY TWO
THREE. HEARING A TEEN NO. TECH
ARE PROMOTING ROOM IN ROOM
TWENTY FOUR THERE IS NO ONE IN
THE AND FORTY LADIES AND THE
COMMITTEE WE NOW LIKE TO BE A
TO GO TO THE LINE WERE GONNA
AND ARM MS MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP THE WHO THE TO
BE JUST INTO IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE SEVENTY TWO ALTERNATE OVER
DO YOU MISTER MODERATOR. YES
MISTER CHAIR AND AGAIN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO PRESS ONE BEEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS MODERATORS CLEAN UP OUR
CALLERS WE WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO MAKE
A LEAN AND THE CLEAN AS OVER
HERE TO OUR RIGHT SHE IS BEEN
THE STEADY HAND BEHIND THE
SCENES MAKING SURE THINGS RUN
SMOOTHLY. SO MUCH MAKING A FOR
ALL OF YOUR EACH WEEK LET'S
TURN IT OVER TO THE MODERATOR
MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES. YES
MISTER CHAIR. A WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO LINE EIGHTY. ONE EIGHTY
OR ONE. MORNING HERE IN THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MORNING MR CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS THE COURT. SOUNDS
LIKE MISS DOWN ON A BEEN IN
TRANSIT TO WE GOT HER TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OF NINE SEVENTY TWO
FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS BAMA. MISTER
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING AS LONG OR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MISTER
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE THIRTY THREE GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MIKE BYNUM UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS SB THIRTY NINE
THIRTY WE APPRECIATE THE
SENATOR KNOWLEDGE IN THE FACT
THAT CALIFORNIA NEED THING DOWN
AND LOCKS TAX REVENUE IN OUR
STATE AND THEY'RE VERY GOOD
FIRST STEP THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
MISTER MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. THERE IS NO
ADDITIONAL OUTLINES CUED UP TO
SPEAK THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
MODERATOR LAST CALL POLICE FOR
THOSE IN SUPPORT CAN YOU PLEASE
DO A LAST CALL FOR SB NINE
SEVENTY TWO SUPPORT. LINE
SEVENTY FIVE IS CUED UP AGAIN
JUST A MOMENT. ONE SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD MORNING
MR. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATOR SET BRAMBLE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER BRAMBLE. MISTER
MODERATOR ANYONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE IN SUPPORT. THERE WAS NO
ONE ELSE MISTER ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER MODERATOR WE
ARE NOW GOING TO TRANSITION
VERNON TRANSITION TO THOSE WHO
MAY BE OPPOSED TO THE BILL. SB
NINE SEVENTY TWO WE HAVE TO
INDIVIDUALS AS THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THE
FIRST IS GOING TO BE TESTING
WHETHER BE REPRESENTED
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION THEN WE'RE GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO NIKKI DOPEY
FROM THE COUNCIL ON STATE
TAXATION. FIRST AND FOREMOST
LET'S GO TO DUSTIN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION MR WEATHERBEE GOOD
MORNING YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. YES HEARING
COMMITTEE YOUR LIFE THE FLOOR
IS YOURS YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES
GOOD MORNING SIR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR SKINNER ABOUT
THE WHAT WOULD BE THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB NINE SEVENTY TWO. CAL
TECH IS LEADING A COALITION
AGAINST THE BILL WHICH VIOLATES
THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS BILL
OF RIGHTS. INFRINGE UPON. I
TAXPAYERS RIGHT TO PRIVACY AND
CONFIDENTIALITY. THIS BILL IS
AN ATTEMPT TO SHANE TAXPAYERS
TO RECEIVE BUSINESS TAX CREDITS
AND TO BE FRANK WE ARE
SURPRISED AT THIS BILL RIGHT IS
THE LEVEL CORD IT'S WITH THIS
BODY SPENT TIME. DEBATE GIVEN
OFFICE GOING ON THE WORLD. THE
BILL REQUIRES THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO PRODUCE AND REPORT ON
CORPORATE TAXPAYERS TO INCLUDE
SUCH COMPANY INFORMATION AS OUR
NAME. TAX LIABILITY HELLO BUT
YOUR SEATS MOUNT CREDITS CLAIM
FOR THE TAXABLE YEAR. THIS BILL
SUBJECTIVELY TARGETS TAXPAYERS
RB. GROSS RECEIPTS THRESHOLD.
AND SINGLE NEEDS BUSINESS OUT
TO HAVE BEEN CONFIDENCE TAX AND-
CHEN THE POP. THERE'S NO CAN.
BE GROSS. AND TAX CREDITS
ADDITIONALLY GROSS RECEIPTS ARE
NOT INCOME. THIS BILL REQUIRES
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO
VIOLATE SEVERAL THEY'RE LISTED
PRINCIPLES A PROTECTION
PROTECTING TAX. INFORMATION
PRIVACY. THE TAXPAYER BILL OF
RIGHTS WHICH THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE PASSED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. THE BILL
ADDITIONALLY REQUIRES A REPORT
ON HOW MANY CREDITS ARE CLEAN
FOR EACH TXABLE YEAR. THESE
CREDITS ARE CLAIMED LEGALLY BY
TAXPAYERS AND BETTER BY
CALIFORNIA'S. TAX AGENCIES TO
ENSURE TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE
BEING USED AND TEN PURPOSE. ACT
MISUSES ACOSTA HELP TAX AGENCY
LEGAL TO ENSURE ALL. THERE
SHARE. YEAH IF YOU CAN PRODUCE
AGGREGATE DATA AS LONG AS NO
INFORMATION TO BE USED TO
IDENTIFY TAX THERE WHICH IS
ENOUGH TO INFORM POLICY
DECISIONS. BY INCLUDING COMPANY
NAMES ONE CAN ONLY ASSUME THIS
IS BEING USED TO HAME
COMPANIES. BY SHAMING TAXPAYERS
YOU LIE TAX CREDITS CALIFORNIA
WILL BE SENDING MESSAGES TO
BUSINESSES. DO NOT YOU DO NOT
UTILIZE CREDITS IN THE STATE DO
NOT DO BUSINESS HERE. THERE'S A
TIME AND PLACE FOR TAX CREDIT
AND IN TIMES SUCH AS BEST WHEN
CALIFORNIA'S UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE CLAIMS THAT SHATTERED
PRIOR RECORDS. EDIT CAN BE A
POWERFUL TO THE MOTOR BECAME.
THIS STATE COMPANY. TO UTILIZE
HIRING CREDIT. THE WORLD NEEDS
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES USE
UTILIZE RESEARCHING THE VELVET
CREDIT. TO INNOVATE AND CREATE
NEW TREATMENTS AND TECHNOLOGIES
MICHAEL THE NINETEEN. WEAVER'S
SPECS WE ASK THIS COMMITTEE CAN
LOOK AT THE STATE'S PRIORITIES
AND REJECT THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
WEATHERBEE WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO MR OBEY FROM THE
COUNTY COUNCIL ON STATE
TAXATION. GOOD MORNING MR OBEY
YOUR IN COMMITTEE YOU ARE NOW
LIVE ON THE LINE. WE ASK THAT
YOU KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO THREE
MINUTES- GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT THE FLOOR IS YOURS. GOOD
MORNING MR CARE CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES MA'AM GOOD MORNING YOU ARE
NOW LIVE IN COMMITTEE YOU ARE
THREE MINUTES THE FLOOR IS
YOURS NIKKI. I THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. FOR THE RECORD MY
NAME IS NIKKI OBEY TESTIFYING
TODAY ON THE HAVE IN THE COUNT
CORN STATE TAXATION. IN
OPPOSITION SB NINE SEVENTY TWO-
BECOME FAULTY TAXATION OF THE
NONPROFIT TRADE ASSOCIATION. WE
HAVE A POTENTIALLY FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY MEMBERS- INTERSTATE AND
INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS. OUR
MISSION IS TO PROMOTE AND
PRESERVE THE EQUITABLE AND NON
DISCRIMINATORY STATE AND LOCAL
TAXATION. OF MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL BUSINESS SAYS.
I'M WE STAND UNITED WITH CAL
TAX IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
BECAUSE FRANKLY WE THINK IT.
BAD TAX POLICY FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL DOES IN FACT VIOLATE
FEDERAL LAW SPECIFICALLY I ARE
THE SECTION SIXTY ONE. ZERO
THREE WHICH PROHIBITS EIGHT
FROM DISCLOSING ANY RETURN OR
RETURN INFORMATION. I WOULD
ADVISE THE COMMITTEE THAT
RETURN INFORMATION WITHIN THE
PROVISION IS BROADLY DEFINED TO
INCLUDE PACKED THEIR IDENTITY
AS WELL AS THE AMOUNT OF
INCOME. AND BECAUSE THE BE-
CALIFORNIA A CORPORATE ECONOMY.
TAX IS BASED ON FEDERAL
CORPORATE FEDERAL INCOME I
WOULD CAUTION THE COMMITTEE
THAT THIS VERY WELL COULD
VIOLATE HIS PROVISION OF
FEDERAL CODES- WHICH WOULD PUT
AT RISK THE FTV THE ABILITY TO
OBTAIN INFORMATION FROM THE
IRAQ- CONSIDERING BACKING GRAVE
LEGAL REST I WOULD ASK THIS
COMMITTEE WHY WHY WOULD YOU GO
SO FAR AS TO. ESSENTIALLY
PRECLUDE THE F. T. V. FROM
INFORMATION SHARING- WITH THE
IRAQ FOR. SIMPLY THE PURPOSE OF
I WOULD TAKE PUBLICLY SHAMING
CORPORATION- SENSE OF THE
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE ON AN
AGGREGATE BASIS THAT- THE
COMMITTEE DEFINITELY COULD WORK
WITH THE F. T. B. ON OBTAINING
INFORMATION IN AN AGGREGATE
MANNER WITH RESPECT TO THE
PACIFIC INDUSTRIES IF THERE
WERE CONCERNED. ABOUT THE
TICKET CREDIT AND HOW THOSE
WOULD BE YEARS YOU SIMPLY DO
NOT NEED SPECIFIC TAX
INFORMATION TO MAKE POLICY
DECISIONS I'M THE ONLY OTHER
REASON THAT WE CAN THINK THAT
THE AGGREGATE INFORMATION ISN'T
SUFFICIENT FOR POLICY MAKERS
AND WE BY NO MEANS BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS- ANY TRUTH TO THAT. IS
THAT THERE'S SOMETHING THE
COMMITTEE ISN'T TALKING ABOUT
WHAT THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD OF
DEALING WITH THE FACT TO
TAXPAYERS AGAIN WE ARE BY NO
MEANS SAYING THAT THAT IS THE
CASE- BUT THAT WOULD BE THE
ONLY REASON THAT YOU WOULD NEED
TO ATTACK TAX. INFORMATION AS
WELL. FINALLY I WOULD. THIRTY
SECONDS. I'M I KNOW I WOULD
JUST MAKE ONE WITH THE TOOK
MADE EARLIER REGARDING THE
LEVEL OF CORPORATE INCOME TAXES
GOING DOWN- THIS BILL ALSO DOES
NOT. HOW ANY OF THE OTHER TAX
WILL BE PAID BY CORPORATIONS
INCLUDING PROPERTY TAX AND
SALES AND USE TAX SO THEREFORE
WE- STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL
AND URGE I KNOW ABOUT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER BAY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WE'RE
GOING TO TURN THIS OVER TO THE
MODERATOR MISTER MODERATOR
WORKING AT ALL EXCUSE ME I
APOLOGIZE WE'RE GONNA ACTUALLY
STICK RIGHT HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. THAT CHRIS
MCKAY THESE ABOUT THROW CHAIRED
ME AS HE'S WALKING UP. WE'RE
GONNA START WITH OPPOSITION
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM MISS MCKINNY
PLEASE NEVER MISTER CHAIR-
THANK YOU CHRISTMAS KAYLEE ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPUTING
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
CENTER SKINNER'S BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SECURELY GRATEFUL WE LIKELY TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM IN THE ROOM HERE FORTY
TWO OR THREE. I WOULD LIKE TO
BE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
XENON WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING
OVER TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY FROM
TWENTY FORTY. CRICKETS PROGRAM
NOW- I'D TURN IT OVER. TO THE
PONE LINES LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE'RE GOING TO ASK IN
THE MODERATOR MISTER MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION. OF SB NINE SEVENTY
TWO NOW. YES MISTER CHAIR AND
AGAIN- TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THE NERO
PRESSED ONE THEN ZERO. I WILL
GO TO THE LINE OF LINE EIGHTY
FIVE GOOD MORNING OF. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JUSTIN HIGHER
WITH THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. MISTER
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE NINETY GOOD MORNING BOB
GOOD MORNING. HI THIS IS JIM
LIMBURGER UP HALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF
THAT NINE SEVEN TWO THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT NO WORRIES THANK YOU
SO MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WINE SEVENTY SEVEN GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING SIR MEMBERS CAME
INTO THE TREE ON THE HOUSE AND
TECHNO WE RESPECT ME BECAUSE
THE BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT CALLER MODERATOR. LINE
EIGHTY THREE GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MARIN HIGGINS ON BEHALF
OF BY CALM AND THE ADVANCED
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER IS A MODERN. LINE
SEVENTY SIX GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING PRESS TOO YOUNG FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. MISTER
MODERATOR THE CHECK IN WITH OUR
NEXT CALLER. THERE ARE NO OTHER
CALLERS TO KILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER MODERATOR MISTER
MODERATOR ONE LAST CALL FINAL
CALL FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION OF
NINE SEVENTY TWO CAN YOU PLEASE
DO THAT NOW. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO IF YOU WIH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. HOW WE LOOKING
SMARTER. THERE IS NO INSTALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH LAYS IN
GENERAL COMMITTEE WERE NOW
GOING TO BE BRINGING IT HERE IN
PERSON IN PERSON. I'M SORRY WE
ALREADY DID THAT WE'RE BACK T
COMMITTEE MY GOODNESS WE'RE
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO BOTH
ASSN WINNER IN THE MAJORITY
LEADER PLEASE. THANK YOU FIFTY
THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIRMAN- I
SUPPORT THIS BILL I DO WANNA
THANK THE- AUTHOR FOR HER
PERSISTENCE IN ADDRESSING SOME
OF THE REAL. INEQUITIES WE HAVE
AROUND CORPORATE TAXATION. IN
THIS STATE I DO WANT TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS- TE LEAD
WITNESS HAD. MADE A POINT OF
WHY ARE WE CONSIDERING THIS NOW
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND THIS
DOESN'T SEEM TO RISE TO THE
LEVEL I ACTUALLY THINK. IT DOES
AND I THINK IT ACTUALLY IS
TIED. TO OR EXPERIENCE NOW WHAT
COVE IN NINETEEN. HAS DONE IN
MANY WAYS IT'S CAST A SPOTLIGHT
VERY BRIGHT SPOTLIGHT ON SOME
OF THE REAL- INEQUITIES AND
PROBLEMS AND DEFICIENCIES. IN
OUR SOCIETY AND OUR APPROACH TO
GOVERNANCE. NOT EVERYONE HAD
REALLY FOCUSED ON BEFORE A
NUMBER OF US DID. NOT EVERYONE-
AND ONE OF THOSE DEFICIENCIES.
IS THE COME THE COMPLETE
INADEQUACY OF OUR SOCIAL SAFETY
NET. IN CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONALLY IN A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE EXPERIENCING THAT LACK OF A
SAFETY NET NOW FOR THE FIRST
TIME. BECAUSE A MORE SECURE
BEFORE THEY'RE NOT NOW AND THEN
REALIZING ALL MY GOD- THERE'S-
A LIKE WHAT DOES NOTHING TO
PREVENT. OR NOT ENOUGH TO
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM FREE
FALLING. AT ONE OF THE REASONS.
UP FOR THE LACK OF AN ADEQUATE
SAFETY NET IS BECAUSE WE HAVE
AN INADEQUATE TAX SYSTEM THAT
DOESN'T ARTICLE ADEQUATELY TAX.
RICH CORPORATIONS BUT DOESN'T
ADEQUATELY TAX WEALTH. AND WHEN
WE LOOK AT CORPORATE TAXATION
WE KNOW. BECAUSE SOMETIMES
INFORMATION GETS OUT THAT SOME
OF THE LARGEST CORPORATIONS IN
THE WORLD. PAY LITTLE OR NO.
FIVE CORPORATE INCOME TAX. HI
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE
SYSTEMATIC DATA WHICH I THINK
IT WILL SHOW SOME VERY VERY
INTERESTING RESULTS AND MAY
ACTUALLY BE INSTRUCTIVE AND
HELPFUL IN TRYING TO HAVE A
MORE EQUITABLE SYSTEM OF
TAXATION OF FOR CORPORATIONS
FOR THE THOUGHT ACCEPTABLE.
WHEN YOU KNOW CORPORATION LIKE
IT'S AN AMAZON OR SOMETHING
ELSE IS PAYING SUCH A LITTLE.
IN INCOME TAX. SO WE LOOK AT IT
RESPONDING TO COVER NINETEEN.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT OUR TAX
SYSTEM WE NEED TO LOOK AT
TAXATION. AND THIS VERY BASIC
DATA IS NOT A VIOLATION OF
PRIVACY THIS IS ABOUT. HOW MUCH
TAX YOU PAYING AND HOW MAY TAX
EXEMPTIONS ARE YOU GETTING VERY
VERY BASIC INFORMATION- AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I MOVED
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH IS
CENTER WIENER WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR WE THREE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK FROM THE COMMITTEE WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE MINORITY LEADER
THAN WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE VICE
CHAIR THAN CENTER HER TITLE
MISS MAJORITY LEADER THE FLOORS
ARE SIR. AS A LISTEN TO THIS
DEBATE. THERE'S ASSUMPTIONS ARE
BEING MADE. I THINK A WRONG.
THE REALITY IS THAT THERE ARE
SOME TAX CREDITS ARE GOOD. THAT
WE CAN USE TAX POLICY IN THE
WAY THAT SUPPORTS IMPORTANT
PUBLIC POLICY. THE QUESTION
HERE IS A MANAGEMENT QUESTION.
ANY CFO OR COO OF ANY COMPANY
THAT'S RUNNING A COMPANY. LOOKS
AT THEIR VARIOUS INDICATORS AND
TRIES TO DETERMINE WHAT'S
WORKING WHAT'S NOT WORKING. I
SERVED IN A CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE WITH WALLY KNOX AND
DIANE WATSON SOME TWENTY YEARS
SOME YEARS AGO ON DEALING WITH
THIS VERY ISSUE AND ONE OF THE
GREAT CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE.
IS AT AS WE COME IN THESE JOBS.
PEOPLE WALKING OR OFFICE THEY
TELL US- DO THIS THIS IS WHAT
IT'S GOING TO DO. COMMON IN
THIS OF SAY THE PROBLEM AND I
ALWAYS SAY TO A ONE OF A DOZEN
YOU GONNA PAY US BACK. RIGHT
YOU BOUGHT A CAR DIDN'T HAVE
ENGINE WELL GIVE US THE MONEY
BACK ITS BASIC POLICY YOU GUYS
WANT US TO. SPEND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF TAXPAYERS MONEY
GOING TO PAY US BACK. WE CAN'T
OBVIOUSLY. AND SO FROM A
MANAGEMENT PERSPECTIVE WHAT YOU
NEED OUR TOOLS AVAILABLE. TO DO
THAT DIAGNOSTIC. AND WHAT I
FOUND IN EVERY TIME I TRY TO
ENGAGE IN ASKING THE
APPROPRIATE QUESTIONS DETERMINE
WHETHER SOMETHING IS WORKING OR
NOT WORKING YOU GET THE KABUKI
YOU GET THE CHANCE TO GET THE
WELL I CAN'T GIVE THE
INFORMATION OR LOOK AT THIS
INDUSTRY AND WILL WE WEREN'T
PART OF THAT INDUSTRY IN THIS
IS NOT THE REASON. AND YOU
DON'T GET TO IT. WE COMBINE I
GET THE ISSUE OF THE SHAMING
PART I THINK IT'S AN
INTERESTING OBSERVATION. BUT
THE REALITY IS WE ARE TRYING TO
RUN A GOVERNMENT THAT. CREATES
THE RIGHT INCENTIVES TO CHOOSE
THE RIGHT OUTCOMES. AND IF
THEY'RE NOT TO CORRECT IT. AND
SO WHY SUPPORT THIS BILL IS
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S GOOD
MANAGEMENT. I THINK THAT THE
ARGUMENTS THAT ARE BEING MADE
AGAINST IT. ARE THE SAME KIND
OF ARGUMENTS ARE BEING MADE
AGAINST SOME OF THE OTHER BILLS
THAT IT'S BASICALLY ABOUT WILL
WE DON'T WANT TO DO THIS AND WE
WANT TO GET WE WANT TO GET. AND
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY IN
GOVERNMENT TO ASK THE TOUGH
QUESTIONS. AND IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT ANY COMPANY THAT WOULD
HAVE. A BUNCH OF TAX CREDITS
SECOND ISSUE STATEMENTS VACANCY
YOU CAN JUSTIFY WHAT THEY'RE
DOING THEY'LL COME BEFORE
HERE'S WITH AN EXAM UP ISSUES.
TERM WHETHER WILL WRITE WHAT
THE WILL WRONG. BUT WHAT WE'RE
ENGAGE IN THIS BIG DEBTS. AND
YOU KNOW THAT'S NO SURPRISE SEE
OF WHICH- SPENT A GREAT DEAL OF
TIME. EITHER IN THE BENEFIT OF
FISH. THIS POLICY WERE
GOVERNMENT SAYS WE'RE GONNA
GIVE YOU THIS THIS BENEFIT AND
YOU SHOULD HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO JUSTIFY TAKING THAT BENEFIT.
SO I AM LISTENED CLOSELY TO THE
ARGUMENTS IN OPPOSITION. AND I
JUST THINK THE- I THINK THEY
COMPORT TO BASIC. PRINCIPLES I
DON'T THINK THAT THEY SHOULD BE
VIEWED IN THE ISSUE OF LABOR
VERSUS MANAGEMENT. THIS IS OUR
JOB AS PUBLIC OFFICIALS. THAT
PROPERLY- A STEWARDS OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS. AND TO
BASICALLY MAKE SURE WE HAVE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES TO ENSURE
THE POLICIES THAT WE ENGAGE IN.
ARE CHEATING THE OUTCOMES THAT
THEY'RE ACHIEVING AND THIS WILL
ALLOW US TO ENGAGE A SPECIFIC
CONVERSATIONS. TO GET TO THAT
GOAL SO I THINK IT'S VERY
THOUGHTFUL. A AND I DON'T THINK
THE CHARACTERS A AS TO HOW IT'S
BEEN LAID OUT IS ACCURATE. AND
I THINK IT'S GOOD MANAGEMENT
THE RIGHT THING TO DO AND
THAT'S ONE WITH A VOTE FOR THIS
BILL TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MAJORITY LEADER MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO
TURN ON THE VICE CHAIR THAN
SOONER HER TITLE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MAYBE I'LL
PICK UP OR SENATOR HERTZBERG
LEFT OFF I. I THINK HE MAKES
SOME VERY STRONG. POINTS BUT I
DON'T THINK THE ISSUE IS THAT
WE DON'T TAX ENOUGH. WHAT'S
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THIS BODY
KEEPS APPROVING TAX CREDITS.
AND IT DOESN'T ANALYZE. WHAT
THEY DO. BUT IT'S AN INDICTMENT
IT'S AN INDICTMENT OF THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD IT'S AN
INDICTMENT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THAT WE DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT OUR REVENUES ARE AND WHAT
ARE. TAX EXPENDITURES ARE. AND
SO NOW WE'RE SAMPLING. WITH A
GROUP OF CORPORATE CITIZENS
THAT EARN A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
TOTAL REVENUES AND I THINK IT'S
BAD MANAGEMENT I AGREE WITH THE
SENATOR FROM HELL TAKE WITH.
IT'S FRUSTRATING TO ME AS
SOMEONE WHO IS AN EXECUTIVE WHO
IS SOMEONE WHO RAN. BUSINESS
AND APARTMENTS IN A COUNTY THAT
WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA IMAGE IS
MIND BOGGLING THIS IS THE
SECOND BILL OF THIS NATURE
WE'VE HAD IN THIS COMMITTEE
THIS YEAR SO FAR. MISTER CHAIR
SO. IT'S A LOAN BURSTING TO ME
WE FILED ELECTRONICALLY. WE
HAVE THE DATA ELECTRONICALLY WE
HAVE A GOVERNOR WHO'S JUST INTO
DIGITAL. INNOVATION WHICH THE
CLAIMS THAT HE SENT TO DIGITAL
INNOVATION. ALTHOUGH HE VETOED
A BILL ON ADOPTING XP ARE
HEALTH WHICH IS WHAT EVEN
CHINESE COMPANIES USED TO
MANAGE THEIR CAMPUS I JUST AND
WE SET UP WHEN WE APPROVE FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR DIGITAL
INNOVATIONS SO. YOU COULD TELL
THAT DEPARTMENT TAKE MINE THE
DATA AT THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
AND YOU WOULD PROBABLY PAY FOR
ITSELF. AND MAYBE AS A
FRUSTRATED LEGISLATOR MISTER
CHAIR THIS IS. MAY TWENTY
EIGHTH AND WE STILL DON'T HAVE
OUR- COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL
FINANCIAL REPORT FOR JUNE
THIRTY. TWENTY NINETEEN- BOOK
WHERE IS THE DIGITAL INNOVATION
WHERE WHAT WHAT DO WE NEED
BILLS LIKE THIS WHY CAN'T THIS
STATE RUN LIKE A LIKE LIKE
MAYBE IT HAS SILICON VALLEY
INSIDE ITS BORDERS WITH. SALT
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME VENT A
LITTLE BIT MISTER CHAIRMAN- I'M
JUST I'M JUST AMAZED THAT WE
WERE LOOKING FOR JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF INFORMATION FROM THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. AND TWO
WITNESSES A SAID YOU CAN GET
THAT NOW I CAN GET AND SO I
GUESS MY FIRST QUESTION TO THE
GOOD SENATOR SKINNER WOULD BE
HAVE YOU ASKED FOR THAT
INFORMATION FROM THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD HAVE YOU REQUESTED
THE AGGREGATE DATA JUST TO SEE.
WHAT THE GROSS REVENUES ARE FOR
THIS THIS STRATIFIED SEGMENT OF
THE- TAX. CORPORATE TAXPAYERS
IN. WHAT WE CAN AND THEN WHAT
WHAT ARE THE PERCENTAGES OF
CREDITS ARE GETTING. SENATOR
THROUGH THE CHAIR THESE- SENDER
BY VICE CHAIR I APPRECIATE.
SKIS ME THE QUESTION AND- ARE
HEY PRECIADO ALSO YOUR
ELIMINATING THE ISSUE HERE IS
NOT THAT THE F. TV DOES NOT
HAVE THE STATE THE F. T. B. X.
FIVE RECEIVES THE- TAX FILINGS
OF THESE ENTITIES. IT IS THAT
IT CAN WE CANNOT HAVE ACCESS TO
IT YES THE F. T. B. CAN'T GIVE
IT TO US IN AGGREGATE AND WE
GET IT AN ACTOR AGGREGATE
HOWEVER THAT DOES NOT ASSIST US
IN THE DAY. DO NOT IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US FOR EXAMPLE TO
GET. THE INFORMATION ABOUT. THE
TOTAL VALUE OF TAX FOR NOT
VALUE THE TOTAL. PAYOUTS
BECAUSE ANY TAX CREDIT IS A TAX
EXPENDITURE RIGHT WE KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT WE SPEND ON K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS WE KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT WE SPEND ON MEDI
CAL WE KNOW EXACTLY YOU KNOW ON
AND ON I CAN GIVE THIS WHOLE
LIST BUT EACH INDIVIDUAL TAX
CREDIT WE HAVE MUCH LESS VERY
SPECIFIC BECAUSE WE DON'T ALLOW
IT PUBLICLY. NOW THIS BILL DOES
NOT EVEN GO THAT FAR IT PURELY
GIVES US THE INFORMATION OF THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF TAX CREDIT A
PARTICULAR ENTITY. I AM NOT
TALKING A CORPORATION WITH
GROSS RECEIPTS OF FIVE BILLION
OR MORE NOW THE OTHER THING I
DIDN'T MENTION THIS ONLY COVERS
FOUR TO FIVE POINT FOUR HUNDRED
TO FIVE HUNDRED COMPANIES AND
THESE COMPANIES DO NOT HAVE TO
BE CALIFORNIA HEADQUARTERS.
THERE ACROSS THE US SO I FOUND
IT VERY INTERESTING TO HEAR THE
OPPOSITION TALK ABOUT
INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYERS THIS IS
NOT AFFECT WHAT YOU AND I
USUALLY THINK OF AS AN
INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER ANY VICE
CITY ON THE DICE IT ONLY
AFFECTS FOUR HUNDRED TO FIVE
HUNDRED COMPANIES CORPORATIONS
ACROSS THE US. THAT IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE GROSS RECEIPTS
OF FIVE BILLION OR MORE. IN MY
PURPOSE IS NOT TO SHAME BUT
THAT YOU DIDN'T ASK THAT SO
ANYWAY YES I CAN GET YOU CAN'T
I CAN'T. THAT AGGREGATE DATA
WHICH IS WHY WE KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE. THAT CORPORATE INCOME
TAX REVENUE TO THE STATE IS
RIGHT TODAY ONLY ABOUT- AS OF
LAST YEAR ABOUT 9% OF OUR
COMPLETE GENERAL FUND- BUT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY INDIVIDUAL DATA.
BECAUSE WE BECAUSE OUR LAW
PREVENTS IT HOWEVER ALL THE
OTHER STATES THAT I MENTIONED
IN MY OPENING THEY ALLOW IT. WE
APPROVED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT THE TAXPAYERS BILL OF
RIGHTS WITH THIS. BILL NULLIFY
THAT BILL IS NOT NOTIFY THE
ENTIRE LOT BY ANY MEANS IT
PURELY ENABLES THE F. T. B. TO
PROVIDE US WITH THE TWO DATA
POINTS THAT WAS REITERATED BY.
ONE OF THE- ARE- SEIU
REPRESENTATIVE A PURELY GIVES
US INFORMATION ON TWO DATA
POINTS FOR THOSE FOUR HUNDRED
FIVE HUNDRED COMPANIES WITH
GROSS RECEIPTS OF FIVE BILLION
OR MORE. AND IT WAS STATED THAT
IT VIOLATES INTERVIEW CODE
SECTION SIXTY FIVE. TO SIXTY
SIXTY ONE OH THREE IS THAT
ACCURATE. THAT IS NOT MY
UNDERSTANDING IT IS CERTAINLY
WAS NOT SOMETHING THE ANALYSIS-
IF IT WAS- THERE WAS A VERY
THOROUGH ANALYSIS AND- THAT IS
NOT AN ELEMENT THAT WAS
INCLUDED. SERVICE CAN BY THE
OPPOSITION I'M I'M JUST. I'M
JUST HAVING DIFFICULTY WITH
THIS AND THIS APPROACH AND IT
JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT WE SHOULD
HAVE THIS DATA ALTHOUGH YOU I
BELIEVE IN PRIVACY SO I'M I'M
HAVING A TOUGH TIME EVEN THOUGH
YOU'RE ASKING FOR VERY SPARSE
INFORMATION AYE- BUT IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT THE FRANCHISE TAX
FOR SHOULD BE HELPING US OUT.
AND THERE SHOULD BE LIKE A
REGULAR DRILL OF WHAT IS THIS
CREDIT DOING WITH IT IS IT
DOING WHAT IT WAS DESIGNED AND
IT'S A LITTLE EMBARRASSING TO
ME THAT WE HAVE TO DO A BILL TO
TELL THEM TO YOU THAT'S WHY I
APPLAUD YOU FOR DOING THAT I
AGREE WITH. WE GOT A WE GOT A
PROD SOMEONE TO START MANAGING
WHAT WE'RE DOING- BECAUSE I
THINK THE TAX SYSTEM. COULD
HAVE A LOT OF CHANGES BUT- BUT
TED TED TO NIBBLE AROUND THE
EDGES- IN THIS WAY. I'M HAVING
DIFFICULTY WITH IT SO I WILL BE
OPPOSED. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
TENNIS CAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ANSWER THAT AND WE'RE GOING TO
SONORA THROUGH THE CHAIR. THE
PROBLEM IS IT'S NOT SO MUCH ME
WEEK. WHETHER F. T. B. HAS
THOSE CAPABILITIES OR NOT OF
COURSE WE'D HAVE TO TEST THE
ISSUE IS. OUR OWN STATUTES FOR
BID THEM FROM GIVING US THAT
DATA SO IF YOU RECALL WHEN WE
EXTENDED THE FILM TAX CREDIT
NOW I BELIEVE THAT WAS IN A
SEVENTEEN. YET WHEN WE EXTEND
THE FILM TAX CREDIT. WE
REQUIRED. THE EVERYONE WHO TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF IT TO DISCLOSE
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF INFORMATION
HOW MANY JOBS TO CREATE A WHOLE
VARIETY OF THINGS. BECAUSE IN
THE BECAUSE OUR TAX LAW WOULD
NOT. PROHIBIT US FROM GETTING
THAT INFORMATION SO IN A WAY WE
HAVE CREATED THE BARRIER. OKAY
BECAUSE WE WANT TO GET THE
CENTER TUNNEL PLEASE RAISE YOUR
STRUCTURE AND- THIS YEAR'S
REALLY DIFFICULT- BUT MAYBE WE
OUGHT TO HAVE A HEARING. ON
THIS TOPIC MERITS ARE TALKING
ABOUT OUR TAX SYSTEM CORPORATE
INDIVIDUAL AT A CERTAIN.
REVIEWING WHAT WHAT IT IS WHAT
IT HOW IT COMPARES TO OTHERS IN
WHERE WE CAN IMPROVE IT. AT AND
THAT'S JUST MY RECOMMENDATION
STRUCTURE FOR SHE TEMAS VICE
CHAIR I THINK IT IS ALSO
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THERE IS
A BILL BY SENATOR JACKSON THAT
WAS ADVANCED. LAST WEEK THAT
DID A DOES A FULL EVALUATION
REGARDS THIS TAX CREDITS THAT
WAS PASSED BY THE MAJORITY THIS
COMMITTEE THAT. DOES A DEEP
DIVE ON THE EVALUATION CRATES
COMMITTEE TO BE A LOOK AT THE
CREDITS. AND EFFICACY OF THOSE
<c.green>REDITS SO I THINK THAT WAS</c>
SAID THAT IT WAS RETURNED LAST
YEAR- BUT AND THIS COMMITTEE
DID PASS IT WITH MAJORITY VOTE.
ON THAT ISSUE TO BE TO DO THE
TEST THAT THAT DEEP DIVE. ON
THE ISSUE OF TAX CREDITS TRYING
TO GO TO CENTER AND HOW TO
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OF THE OF NOT ED NECESSARILY
PREPARED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY I HAVE REAL CONCERNS
REGARDING- PUBLICLY DISCLOSING
THAT INFORMATION BUT- I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS. IS
THE RIGHT THING AND I THINK IT.
WOULD NEED TO BE WORKING ON
THAT AND- I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS- WHY NOT GIVE F. T. BEAT THE
ABILITY TO. TO FURTHER INSPECT
THAT THE ADDITIONAL CRITERIA
THAT YOU'RE SEEKING TO. GET OLD
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION SO THAT
THEY COULD MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION OF WHETHER OR NOT
THE FACT THAT THAT THAT. THAT
TAX CREDIT ELIGIBILITY AND I
THINK THAT. MIGHT MAKE IT MORE
IMMEDIATE DIFFERENCE IN TERMS
OF THE SEASONS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE TERROR PLEASE.
ON THE DIFFICULTY IS OUR WHILE
SOMETIMES WE FEEL THAT AGENCIES
OVERREACH OUR OVERSTAFFED OUR
AGENCIES ARE RESPONSIBLE TO
IMPLEMENTING POLICY WE DIRECT
AND THEY ARE NOT THEMSELVES IN
FACT THEY CANNOT INITIATE
POLICY OR OR- I MEAN IN EFFECT
WHAT YOU ARE DESCRIBING WHICH I
AGREE WITH. IS EIGHT IS. A
POLICY ON IS PUTTING HAVE TO BE
IN THE POSITION OF AN OF
ENACTING POLICY FOR WHICH WE
HAVE NOT DIRECTED THEM TO DO SO
AND SO. UNTIL WE- GIVE THEM THE
RIGHT TO BASICALLY PROVIDE US
WITH THIS. INDIVIDUALIZED DATA
THEN IT NEITHER NEITHER CAN NAY
RECOMMEND POLICY NOR CAN WE-BECAUSE TECHNICALLY IT WE HAVE.
BY STE BY. BY THE PRIVACY
ELEMENTS OF OUR TAX LAW WHICH
ARE VERY IMPORTANT I AM NOT
TRYING TO ON UP TURNER ON TURN
ALL THE PRIVACY ELEMENTS OF OUR
TAX LAW BUT DUE TO THOSE THE F.
T. B. IS A PROHIBITED FROM
CERTAIN- FROM GIVING A CERTAIN
INFORMATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
INNING ON CETER TOWN. WILL BE
IT THANK YOU I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONVERSATION
FROM THIS COMMITTEE FOR RETURN
RISEN AS SKINNER FOR CLOTHES.
THAT ONE THING PLEASE THANKS
SENATOR RAISED A PORTENT POINT
I. MY ONLY EXPERIENCE IN UNITED
SUPPORT THESE THINGS MANY YEARS
AGO. THE REASON I SUPPORTED
TODAY IS BECAUSE- WE'VE JUST
TRIED EVERYTHING UNDER THE SUN
YOUR MEAN THIS IDEA OF. AS
CENTERS SKINNER TALKED ABOUT
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND YOU
KNOW THE IT MUST BE GIVEN
DIRECTIONS STOCK IN A HAPPEN.
YOU WE'VE GOT THIS VERY DEAL
DELICATE DANCE IN THIS TAX
THING AND WE'VE JUST AT SOME
POINT I MEAN I'M AT THE POINT
QUITE FRANKLY WHERE. I DON'T OF
OURS WORDS OF MIKE THIS TEN
YEARS AGO BUT I AND I'M
SUPPORTING IT NOW AS A RESULT
OF WATCHING THIS AND STILL MORE
MORE TAX CREDITS WHICH IS OFTEN
THE RIGHT THING TO DO I'M NOT
OBJECTING TO THAT SOMETIMES IT
MAKES SENSE. I JUST WANT TO
KNOW HOW THEY WORK AND NEED
PRACTICAL TOOLS TO FIGURE THAT
OUT. AND WE'VE TRIED SO MANY
THINGS OVER THE YEARS THE
REASON I'M CONCERNED AND WANT
TO GO TO THIS ROUTE THINK THAT.
CENTER SKINNER BILLS GOOD IS
BECAUSE I THINK THAT WE HAVE TO
DO THIS TO MAKE IT EFFECTIVE
OTHERWISE WE'RE JUST ENGAGED IN
THE VORTEX OF NOTHINGNESS AND-
WE HAVE ANOTHER TWENTY YEARS
AND DON'T MOVE THE BALL DON'T.
WE JUST KICKING THE CAN DOWN
THE ROAD SO TO SPEAK SO THAT'S
WHY I THINK WHICH IS DOING IS
INTELLIGENCE WANTED TO ADD THAT
IN. TO WHAT YOU ALREADY SAID
SENATOR. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MAJORITY LEADER SENATOR ANY
LAST. MINUTE COMMENTS FOR CLOSE
I WOULD ONLY DO MICHAEL. ART
THANK YOU SOME. LEASING JENNA
COMMITTEE THIS IT DOES HAVE A
MOTION THAT'S ON THE FLOOR IN
OTHER WORDS I WOULD DO A CLOSE
BUT I DIDN'T KNOW IF THAT'S
WHAT YOU WERE YES I'M SORRY I
TELL YOU TO YOUR NEW CAR ASKING
TO CONTEST HERTZBERG WORK
CLOTHES A WOULD APPRECIATE
BEING ABLE CLIPS FEES. THANK
YOU FOR THIS GREAT DEBATE. I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE SB NINE
SEVEN TWO DOES NOT RAISE TAXES
IT DOES NOT ELIMINATE ANY TAXES
AND IT COVERS. CORPORATIONS
THAT. DO BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA
BUT THEY'RE NOT HEADQUARTERED
THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE
HEADQUARTERED HERE SO IT'S NOT
JUST GOING AFTER CALIFORNIA
CORPORATIONS IT IS PURELY
GIVING US AS POLICY MAKERS AND
THE PUBLIC SOME INFORMATION
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
APPROPRIATELY EVALUATE OUR
EXPENDITURES. AND HAVE AN
INFORMED DEBATE AROUND WHEN WE
ARE MAKING EXPENDITURE CUTS NOW
THIS IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
DURING A DOWNTURN AS WE ARE NOW
DISCO BUT NINETEEN INDUCED
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN WHERE IN THE
BUDGET THE GOVERNOR'S PRESENTED
TO US THAT'S A FIFTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS OF CUTS. AND
WHILE I AM NOT POSING RIGHT NOW
AT ALL ANY REDUCTION OR
ELIMINATION OF TAX CREDITS IT
IS VERY DIFFICULT TO EVALUATE.
OTHER EXPENDITURE CUTS THAT ARE
IN THAT BUDGET WITHOUT HAVING
FULL ACCESS TO DATA ON ALL OF
OUR DIFFERENT EXPENDITURES AND
OF COURSE TAX CREDITS ARE A BIG
EXPENDITURE NOW THE TOTAL VALUE
OF TAX CREDITS WITHIN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR EVERY HE IS
LIKE IN THE SEVENTY BILLION%
ORDER. SO IN A WAY WE SHOULD BE
DOING A DATABASE THAT COVERS
ALL OF THEM BUT THAT WOULD BE
QUITE EXPENSIVE IN QUITE SO I'M
TRYING TO START MODESTLY. AND I
FOUND THE DEBATE WITH
OPPOSITION IN A AND THE
SUPPORTERS VERY FASCINATING WE
SOUND LIKE YOUR CLASSIC KINDA
LEFT RIGHT IN AND- IT SHOULD
NOT BE REDUCED TO THAT THIS
SHOULD BE REALLY A DEBATE
AROUND THE INFORMATION THE
PUBLIC. AND POLICY MAKERS NEED
TO MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
WHICH WE DON'T HAVE. AND WHILE
THERE IS A REFERENCE TO SHAME
I'M NOT SURE- WHO WHO BROUGHT
IT UP FOR WHAT COMMON MAYBE IT
WAS A LETTER OF OPPOSITION.
THAT IS NOT MY PURPOSE. WE
ALREADY KNOW FROM THE SEC
FILINGS WHAT LARGE COMPANIES
DON'T PAY ANY FEDERAL TAXES SO
BUT THE PURPOSE FOR ME IS NOT
SHAME IT'S PURELY. FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO. HAVE INFORMATION THAT
CAN ALLOW US I WAS BUDGET YEAR
DURING PART OF THE DOWNTURN.
AND NOT HAVING GOOD ACCESS TO.
THIS TYPE OF INFORMATION MAKES
THE ABILITY TO DEBATE
EXPENDITURES AND CUTS VERY
DIFFICULT. MILEAGE PACKAGE
STARTED OUT WITH TWENTY TWO
BILLS IN THIS SESSION. IT IS
NOW DROPPED TO FIVE ORIGINALLY
DROPPED TWO TO FOUR BUT I WAS
ASKED BY COUPLE COMMITTEES TO
BRING ONE OF THEM BACK. SO I
HAVE FIVE AND IT WAS RACED WHY
pI HAVE THIS ONE RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE WE ARE ABOUT WE ALREADY
WE HAVE BUDGET COMMITTEE THIS
AFTERNOON WE ARE GOING TO BE
DEBATING. FIFTY FOUR BILLION IN
TAX IN SKEWS ME IN SPENDING
CUTS BUT AGAIN WE- THERE'S SO
MUCH INFORMATION WE DON'T CALF.
SO WITH THAT. I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
SOONER SKINNER JUST WANNA CLEAR
IF I KNOW THAT IT CAME UP IN
THE DEBATE DID THIS BILL DOES
NOT DISCLOSE FEDERAL INCOME. IT
WOULD BE PROBLEMATIC DID BUT IT
pTHAT WE CLARIFY THAT BEFORE WE
CLOSE DEBATE ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR THIS IS A
DO PASSES AN INTEGER
PREPARATIONS. THAT MOTION WAS
MADE BY SENATOR WIENER. HEARING
THAT ALL DISCUSSION HAS SEIZE
RENEGE ENTERED THE ROOM MISTER
NOW FOR ROLL CALL PLEASE.
BETTER MCGUIRE HI WATER HI
SENATOR MORLOCK. OR LOG NO
SENATOR BELL ALL RIGHT WELL HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG BY
SENATOR TADO. SENDER NIELSEN
FENDER NIELSEN NO CENTER WIENER.
WIENER I. FORTY TWO THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER NOW LAYS IN
GERMAN THAT IS A FOUR TO VOTE
FOR TO VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE CLOSING
THE ROLE ON ITEM SB NINE
SEVENTY TWO THAT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF COMMITTEE WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO SENATOR SKINNER
SECOND BILL IN JUST ONE MOMENT
SIR SKINNER WE HAVE TO SOME
BRIEF HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS THAT
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE
OF IN THIS IS ON SB THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE WHICH AT THIS
COMMITTEE HEARD IT LAST WEEK
AND- AS YOU ALL KNOW MEMBERS AT
WE HERE AT GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE TAKE A LOT OF PRIDE IN
OUR WORK- IN ENSURING THAT THE-
MANY PROCESSES. TO ALL MEMBERS
AND TRAIN AND OF COURSE TO
PUBLIC HOWEVER WE HAD A BIT OF
A SNAFU LAST WEEK WITH SB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE SENATE
GLACIER WHICH I'D LIKE TO BE A
JUST. A BRIEF MOMENT TO EXPLAIN.
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS WE ARE
CLEARLY MISSING MISALIGNED
CHESTER- SO MISS LANE CHESTER
IS OUR COMMITTEE SECRETARY. AND
I SECOND THAT MOTION. WE
ADJOURNED WITHOUT LIFTING THE
CALL ON SB THIRTEEN FORTY NINE
WHICH MEANT THE BILL FAILED
WITHOUT HAVING BEEN GRANTED
RECONSIDERATION NOW SENATE
RULES THANK YOU SO MUCH GIVE
THIS AN OPTION FOR ENSURING
THAT THE SNAFU WILL NOT AFFECT
THE PROGRESS A SINNER GLAZERS
BILL. THIRTY DAY WE WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO ASK THIS
COMMITTEE GRANT RECONSIDERATION
WITH UNANIMOUS CONSENT IF YOU
ARE ALL AGREEABLE BECAUSE IT AS
SENATE RULES DOES NOT ALLOW THE
BILL TO THAT FAILS TO BE HEARD
ON THE SAME HEARING THAT WE
WHEN E GRANT RECONSIDERATION.
AND IT'S A NON FISCAL BILL
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO HEAR THAT
DEAL NEXT WEDNESDAY- IF IT
WORKS FOR FOLKS WE WON'T EVEN
HAVE SENATOR GLACIER COME BACK
SINCE- IT WAS A BIPARTISAN VOTE
I WOULD JUST DO A BRIEF
PRESENTATION ON HIS BEHALF. IN
AGAIN IF THERE IS NO OBJECTION.
CAN WE PLEASE YEAH GRANT
RECONSIDERATION FOR SB THIRTEEN
FORTY A MONTH WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG- IN AND-
MISTER NOW LET'S JUST DO A
QUICK ROLL CALL FOR
RECONSIDERATION. OF THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE. THE FIRST ENTRY IS
CURRENTLY CONSIDERING CENTER
MCGUIRE HI BARB. SENATOR MORAL.
ON WILL WORK ON SENATOR BILL I
STILL ON SENATOR HERTZBERG HIGH
HERTZBERG ARMY SENATOR TADO HI
RICARDO HI SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI SENATOR WIENER
WIENER OUR SORRY THAT THE SEVEN
ZERO A RECONSIDERATION IS
GRANTED THANK YOU SO MUCH BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR THAT-
THAT- THAT MOVE AND ALSO WANTED
MOMENT TO SAY TO SIGNAL ITS
CONGER NOW HE'S CHIEF
CONSULTANT FOR GOVERNS IN
FINANCE THIS GUY'S BEEN WORKING
OVERTIME- EACH AND EVERY WEEK
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL DETAILS
ARE HANDLED IN CON WE CAN BE
DOING THIS I JUST I JUST WANTED
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK.
ALL RIGHT PLACE CHEN THIS
SECOND BILL I NOW HAVE A CENTR
SKINNER STOCK AT THIS IS SB
THIRTEEN HUNDRED WE DO HAVE AN
INDIVIDUAL HERE MISTER TORTILLA
TESTIFYING PERSON AND THEN WE
ALSO HAVE- TO KIM WHO BE ON THE
LINE FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
SHALL BE ON THE PHONE. SKINNER
FOR SURE ZIP. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SB THIRTEEN IS IN CRAFTED BILL
IT ALLOWS DEPARTMENT OF FINE TO
GO THIS OF HER. A FINDING OF
COMPLETION FOR THEIR
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY
DISSOLUTION AND GIVEN HOW MUCH
I DROP MY BILL PACKAGE YOU
MIGHT WONDER WHY MY CARRIED
THIS BILL RIGHT NOW I'M
CARRYING IT BECAUSE SINCE THE
US OUR- STATUTORY DEADLINE FOR.
AGENCY DISSOLUTION IS PASSED WE
HAVE TO DO THIS IN ORDER FOR
HERCULES TO BE ABLE TO AND THE
REASON THAT HERCULES COULD NOT
IN THE PAST WAS THERE WAS A
LAWSUIT BETWEEN THE STATE AND
THE CITY OF HERCULES THAT
LAWSUIT IS SETTLED. AND THE
CITY HAS COMMITTED TO FULLY
MAKE ALL OF ITS PAYMENTS TO THE
STATE AND IS ALREADY STONE GOOD
FAITH AND MADE ME IN ONE
ADDITIONALLY THE ANALYSIS THIS
POINTS OUT THAT SOME OF THE
PROBLEM WITH HERCULES WAS SOME
BAD MANAGEMENT COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE IDENTIFIED OTHERS ALL
THOSE INDIVIDUALS NO LONGER
WORK FOR THE CITY THE CITY'S
DONE A COMPLETE CLEAN UP. A BIT
SIDE ENTIRE EXECUTIVE STAFF AND
IS IN MUCH BETTER SHAPE THAN IT
NEEDS THIS EXEMPTION IN EFFECT
BECAUSE IT HAS TO REFINANCE THE
BONDS IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THE REST OF ITS PAYMENTS
TO THE STATE SO THIS BENEFITS
US IS THE STATE ARE REVENUE IF
WE ALLOW THEM THIS- FINDING OF
COMPLETION AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO
MUCH IS SENATOR SKINNER WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO BE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT TODAY WE JOHN DOUGHERTY
WHO'S BEEN VERY PATIENT MISTER
ANY THANKS FOR HANGING WITH
THIS. REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
HERCULES YOUR THREE MINUTES
ARE- MISTER MEMBERS- GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU. JOHN DORY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY FOR. THE
SENATE HAS DONE A GREAT JOB
EXPLAINING WHY THIS BILL MAKES
FOR. AND SENSE OF I JUST WANT
TO QUICKLY ADDRESS TWO ISSUES
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP. BOTH
DIRECTLY AND INDIRECTLY BY THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS- THE FIRST
WHICH IS PROBABLY THE MOST
TELLING AND MOST OBVIOUS THIS
IS NOT A TYPICAL. REDEVELOPMENT
BILL WE ARE NOT TRYING TO RE
LITIGATE THAT ISSUE. THOSE
BILLS FREQUENTLY HAVE- LOCAL
ENTITIES FIGHTING OVER A SET
STREAM. THE PURPOSE OF THIS
LEGISLATION IS TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE HISTORICALLY
LOW. INTEREST RATES AND CREATE
SAVINGS FOR ALL THE LOCAL
ENTITIES. SO WE'RE LOOKING OUT
OVER THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS OF
UP TO FORTY TWO MILLION
LOCALLY- TWENTY FIVE THAT
MILLION OF THAT GOING TO LOCAL
SCHOOLS. THIS IS A GOOD TIME TO
BE FINDING WAYS THAT DON'T COST
THE STATE MONEY. BUT TO ALLOW
FOR THE SAVINGS THE SECOND
ISSUE IS ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
AGAIN THIS IS NOT RE OPENING A
REDEVELOPMENT WE DID OUR
RESEARCH ARE ONLY EIGHT OTHER
CITIES. THAT ARE IN THIS
PARTICULAR- CIRCUMSTANCES
HERCULES AND- NONE OF THEM ARE
LOOKING TOWARDS- TRYING TO.
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS PATHWAY.
AND FRANKLY IT IT'S MADE IT
EASY FOR US TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION AT
THIS JUST BE. FOCUSED ON THE
CITY OF HERCULES SO FOR THOSE
REASONS- AND FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY THE AUTHOR WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SAYS IT COMES ONLINE JUST
FOR QUESTIONS ABOUT FINANCIALS
ARE BOND FINANCING OR ANY
ANYTHING THE COMMITTEE MIGHT
WANT TO ASK. THANK YOU SO MUCH
DIRTY APPRECIATED TESTIMONY
LADIES IN GENERAL COMMITTEE
WE'RE GONNA SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE OUT HERE IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE ANYONE ELSE IN FORTY TWO
OR THREE WITH ACTIVITY
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. PLEASE COME FORTH. WE
KNOW WE'RE NOT LOOKING TO OUR-
HERE ROOM IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. HE
GUESTED YOU'RE RIGHT NO ONE IS
OUR IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY WERE
NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR
PHONE LINES WE'VE BEEN MISSING
MISTER MODERATOR MISTER
MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA Q. FOLKS
UP. FOR KILLING FOLKS UP IN
SUPPORT OF SB. THIRTEEN HUNDRED
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE MAKE THAT ANNOUNCEMENT.
YES MISTER. PLEASE GERMAN
PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO.
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO. WAIT FOR
FOLKS BEING KIDNAPPED THANKS
EVERYBODY FOR THE PATIENTS AND
FOR THE WORK TODAY MISTER
MODERATOR HOW WE LOOKING IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN HUNDRED
ANY CALLERS ON THE LINE. I
BELIEVE WE MAY HAVE ONE. ONE
ONE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING
LINE TWENTY THREE. ALL RIGHT
MISTER MODERATOR I DON'T THINK
WE HAVE ANYONE ON THAT LINE IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE. IN THE QUEUE.
THERE IS NOONE MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR WERE VERY GRATEFUL
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
COMMITTEE YOU WE'RE NOW GOING
TO ASK FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION. LET'S START WITH
THE PHONE LINES TO START WITH
THE PHONE LINES WERE LOOKING
FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION. OF SB THIRTEEN
HUNDRED OPPOSITION SB THIRTEEN
HUNDRED MISTER MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE MAKE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT IN GET FOLKS IN
THE QUEUE. LADIES AND GERMAN
PRIEST PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AS WE WAIT TO SEE THERE'S
ANYONE THE Q. ONE REMIND FOLKS
IF YOU'D LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING PLEASE DIAL.
844-291-6364 WITH THE CODE.
622-655-8844. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR THAT PHONE
NUMBER IS ON THE SCREEN NOW.
MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION
OF SP THIRTEEN HUNDRED. MISTER
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE NO ONE IS
IN THE QUEUE LADIES IN JENIN
THE COMMITTEE WERE NOW GOING TO
TURN IT HERE IN PERSON TO ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE THAT SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. RAIN SCENE
KNOWN WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
A REMOTE HEARING ROOM ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY TESTIFYING.
IN OPPOSITION. WE'RE GONNA TURN
IT BACK OVER TO COMMITTEE TO BE
ABLE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. OR IS THERE
A MOTION TO APPROVE. THAT L. E.
WE HAVE A MOTION A GOOD MOTION
BY SENATOR HER TITLE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. IN THE FINAL LAST CALL
FOR COMMENTS WERE IN TURN OVER
THE CENTER SKINNER FOR CLOSE
PLEASE THANK YOU ASKED FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. AT
CENTER TITLE MADE THE MOTION
THAT MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. MR NOW CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI. WATER HI SENATOR
MORLOCK. SENATOR BILL. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR HURTADO I
RICARDO HI SENATOR NIELSEN
WILSON ARE SENATOR WIENER
WIENER ON YOUR FOR VOTES IT'S A
FOUR EIGHT ZERO VOTE WE'RE
GONNA KEEP SEVERAL OPEN SENATE
SKINNER WE'RE GONNA HAVE SOME
FOLKS AT ON SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU BEST JOB TODAY
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT LET'S IN
GERMANY KEEP THAT OPEN- THAT'S
A FOUR ZERO VOTE- WE HAVE TWO
MORE BILLS LAST LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AND WE'RE GONNA BE
TURNING IT OVER IT SHE IS HERE
AND READY TO GO THE LADY IN
RED. WATCH OUT- IT'S SO GOOD TO
SEE CENTER CABALLERO. THANK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER COVER YOUR-
SHE'S GONNA BE MAKING HER WAY
FORWARD. WE GOT TO BE ABLE TO
DO SOME QUICK HOUSEKEEPING ON
THIS BILL. WE'RE GONNA HAVE
MICHAEL WEINBERG MICHAEL
WEINBERG. IN MRS CISNEROS. ALL
ON THE PHONE SO WE CAN PLEASE
PREPARE MISTER WEINBERG
INNOCENTS NEAREST WHO WE
TESTIFYING AS OUR LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE IF WE CAN
PLEASE GET THEM READY TO GO ON
THE PHONE. I'M GONNA TURN IT
OVER TO MS COPYRIGHT BUT BEFORE
I DO I JUST WANT TO TAKE A
SECOND TO SAY THANK YOU.
CABALLERO HAS BEEN PART OF THE
SENATE LEAD. GROUP WHO'S BEEN
WORKING ON HOUSING CENTER
CABALLERO HAS BEEN TENACIOUS IN
HER FIGHT. THAT BOTH AS A
MEMBER OF THIS LEGISLATURE AND
A FORMER. REPRESENTATIVE THE
PREVIOUS. MINISTER ON ISSUES
HOUSING. IS A COMMON SENSE.
COMMONSENSE BUT WILL FOCUS ON
DAILY DIET MALLS IS AS A OLD
OFFICE PARKS IN MAKING SURE
WE'RE ABLE. TO ACCOMPLISH THAT
CALIFORNIA DREAM IN GIVEN.
HOUSING AND TURN THE FLOOR OVER
YOU. BUT MANSON IN A SAFE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THE HARDEST ON MY ENTIRE
POLITICAL CAREER IN SHOW. THIS
BILL IF YOU KNOW THEY SAY DON'T
FALL IN LOVE WITH YOUR BILLS
BUT THAT THIS IS NEAR AND DEAR
TO MY HEART AND THANK YOU IT AS
WELL FOR. SHARING THAT- WORKING
GROUP BECAUSE IT IT WAS A REAL
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT AND-
HELPED TREMENDOUSLY TO FRAME MY
THOUGHTS IN THIS ADAPTIVE REUSE
BILL. SO I THINK THE CHAIR IN
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE THE
NEIGHBORHOOD. OWNS ACT. AND I
WANT TO THANK THE STAFF FROM
BOTH THE COMMITTEE AND THE PRO
TEM'S OFFICE FOR THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT THEY PROVIDED.
AND REALLY FOR A GREAT- AN
ANALYSIS THAT I THINK WILL BE
REALLY HELPFUL AS WE AS WE MOVE
ON WITH THIS BILL THEY GOT SOME
GREAT SUGGESTIONS THERE- I'M
HERE TODAY BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO FACE AN EXTREME.
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS IN
ORDER TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S FAMILIES THE STATE
MUST INCREASE HOUSING
PRODUCTION. TO TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS PER
YEAR. YET THE LACK OF AVAILABLE
LAND FOR RESIDENTIAL
pDEVELOPMENT CONTINUES TO BE A
CHALLENGE. MANY OF OUR CITIES
ARE BUILT OUT OR DON'T HAVE
READILY AVAILABLE VACANT LAND
AND OTHER CITIES ARE ELECTED TO
ENCROACH ON THE ADJACENT
PRODUCTIVE FARMLAND. PARK AND A
RANCH LAND. SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE AIMS TO
SPUR HOUSING PRODUCTION BY
AUTHORIZING RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS ON EXISTING LOT
LOT. CURRENTLY ZONED FOR
COMMERCIAL OFFICE AND RETAIL
YOU SUCH AS PART MALLS ARE
LARGE BIG BOX RETAIL SPACE. SB
THIRTY NATIVE I'VE ALSO AIMS TO
SOLVE AND INVOLVED IN EVOLVING
CRISIS. THAT HAS BEEN EXPEDITED
BY THE SHELTER IN PLACE ORDER
DURING THE CALL BUT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. WHICH IS SHIFTED
COMMERCIAL RETAIL TO ONLINE
TRANSACTIONS. NUMEROUS MAJOR
COMMERCIAL TENANTS HAVE
INDICATED THEY MAY BE FILING
FOR BANKRUPTCY RELIEF OR
CLOSING STORES. SEARS JCPENNEY
KMART. TOYS R. US. TO DO THAT
DECLINE IN SALES AT PHYSICAL
STORE LOCATIONS WE HAVE SEEN
THE SHIFTING CONSUMER
PREFERENCE OVER TIME WHICH IS
LEFT. IN MANY COMMUNITIES WITH
STRIP MALLS AND MALLS WITH
MAJOR BIG. WHICH CONTRIBUTE TO
THE DECLINE OF THE RETAIL
CENTER INCREASING BLIGHT.
VANDALISMDECLINE SALES TAX
REVENUE. IN MY DISTRICT THE
RETAILERS ARE MADE TENANTS AND
I LIKE TO SEE MANY MORE
RETAILERS. AT THE DISTRICTS. I
UTILIZED URBAN KOMMER SPACE.
ARE ALLOW MAJOR PUBLIC TRANSIT.
ROUTES THANK SICK ACRE AVAIL TO
BE TO. FOR MAKES USED TO BE. TO
CREATE A ROCK. LIVER WORK PLAY
VILLAGE THE WALKABLE VILLAGE
CONCEPT WILL ALSO HELP TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION.
BY CREATING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF VEHICLE
TRIPS. BY LOCATING SERVICES
WITHIN WALKING DISTANCE TO
PEOPLE FOUND. SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE WILL REQUIRE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT TO MEET OR
EXCEED THE DENSITY DEEMED
APPROPRIATE TO ACCOMMODATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUCH AS
APARTMENTS TOWN HOMES AND
CONDOMINIUMS. SUBJECTED
DEVELOPMENT TO LOCAL PLANNING
PARKING IN DESIGN ORDINANCES.
AND AUTHORIZES LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TO ESTABLISH A COMMUNITY
FINANCE DISTRICT TO PROVIDE FOR
AND MAINTAIN PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND LASTLY THE
BILL WILL ALLOW THE DEVELOPMENT
OF HOUSING BY RIGHT UNDER
CERTAIN LIMITED CONDITIONS
INCLUDED INCLUDING IF A
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY IS VACANT
FOR MORE THAN THREE YEARS AND
IT IT UTILIZES A REALLY GREAT-
BILL THAT WAS PASSED BY SENATOR
WIENER SB THIRTY FIVE THE
ELEMENTS IN THAT BILL. WITH NO
COST TO THE STATE SB THIRTY
EIGHTY FIVE ALL INCENTIVIZE
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT WITHOUT
IMPACTING SINGLE FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOODS BY. GIVING LAND
OWNERS AND DEVELOPERS A WAY TO
MEET THE GROWING DEMAND FOR
HOUSING THE BILL WILL ALSO SPUR
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN REGION'S
MOST IN NEED A REVITALIZED
REVITALIZATION. AND IS A STEP%
TOWARDS ECONOMIC TRANSFORMATION
IT IS SUPPORTED BY A GROWING
NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA FORWARD
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY CALIFORNIA U. M. B.
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY WESTFIELD.
FIND I LOOK FOR TO FURTHER
BUILDING FURTHER SUPPORT AS I
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDRS TO
DISCUSS WAYS TO INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL AFFORDABILITY AND
ANTI GENTRIFICATION MEASURES.
WITH ME TODAY TO PRY TESTIMONY
SUPPORT. IS OUR- MICHAEL
WEINBERG. FROM CALIFORNIA
FORWARD AND JAMAR CISNEROS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PERCENT TODAY
SENATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN
FOR YOUR HARD WORK THIS IS
BEING- A LABOR OF LOVE FOR THE
SENATOR IT IS AN INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF WORK- ON GETTING TO
THIS POINT TO JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE- YOUR HARD WORK IN
YOUR VISION ON THIS BILL. WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE GOING TO OUR LIVE
LINE WE HAVE TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
WILL BE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THAT WE'RE GONNA
START WITH MISTER WEINBERG
MISTER WEINBERG IS THE CEO FROM
CALIFORNIA FORWARD MISTER
WEINBERG YOU WILL HAVE. THREE
MINUTES I'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY
SECOND PROMPT THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOUR NOW LIVE IN
COMMITTEE MISTER WEINBERG.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN. AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MICHAEL WHY WE'RE GOING TO DO
CALIFORNIA BOARD WE'RE PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR AT THE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE. YOUR TIME TODAY
AND ALSO WANT TO ESPECIALLY
THANK THAN- COPY ARE OVER HER
DEALERSHIP ON THIS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. CALIFORNIA
FORTY THE OVEMENT TO MAKE THE
STATE'S ECONOMY AND GOVERNMENT
WORK FOR EVERYONE AND ALL THE
STATE'S REGION'S. AT THE
COMMISSION WE HOST THE ANNUAL
CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC SUMMIT. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN WE HAD A REALLY
GREAT TIME AND THEN HER
FATHER'S NECK OF THE WOODS DOWN
IN FRESNO WE THANK MANY OF THE-
FOLKS ON THE COMMITTEE FOR
JOINING US THERE. IN ADDITION
TO ENJOYING THAT CITIES
REVITALIZED DOWNTOWN WE DID THE
MAX WILL WALK YOU POLICY WORK.
REGULAR WE HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED
TO PRODUCE AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY
OF LAND AVAILABLE FOR HOUSING.
BUT WE CANNOT HOMES ARE
AFFORDABLE WHETHER FOR
HOMEOWNERSHIP OR RENTAL. SINGLE
FAMILY ARE MULTI FAMILY.
INCLUDED THE RECOMMENDATION
THAT HAPPENED UNDER UTILIZED
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY. AT THE
SENATOR MENTIONED. COMMERCIAL
PROPERTY MAKE THAT. IN PRIOR TO
THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC MANY
BRICK AND MORTAR BUSINESSES ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THE GROWTH TO
BE COMMERCE AND THE SHORT MONTH
OF THE CURRENT CRISIS WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN SEVERAL MAJOR
RETAILERS FILED FOR BANKRUPTCY.
UNFORTUNATELY WE SHOULD EXPECT
IF YOU'RE MARKET OBJECT AND
UNDER UTILIZED AND BAKING
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY GOING
FORWARD. SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE CREATE AN ALTERNATE
PATHWAY FOR LANDOWNERS IN
DEVELOPERS THAT WILL HELP MEET
THE GROWING DEMAND FOR HOUSING
BY UTILIZING LAND THAT IS
ALREADY A PART OF THE URBAN
LANDSCAPE. UNDER UTILIZED-
BAKING COMMERCIAL SPACES ARE
OFTEN PRIME LAND CLOSE TO
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION AND
CONTAIN SIGNIFICANT ACREAGE THE
COULD BE DEVELOPED FOR HOUSING
MIXED USE. AS VENDOR DESCRIBED
AT THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
ESSENTIALLY OCTONE COMMERCIAL
AND RETAIL PROPERTIES TO ALLOW
RESIDENTIAL USES AT THE
ENTITIES THAT ARE JEAN
AFFORDABLE BY DESIGN UNDER
EXISTING STATE LAW. DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS WOULD HAVE TO MEET ALL
APPLICABLES STATE AND LOCAL
LAWS AND REGULATIONS.
UNDERSTANDING THE ENORMOUS
STRESS ON THE STATE BUDGET THE
BILL DOES NOT TAKE OUT ANY DAY
FUND AND INSTEAD CREATE AN
INCENTIVE TO BUILD HOUSING THAT
IS AFFORDABLE BY DESIGN. WE
BELIEVE IT IS A REASONABLE
COMMONSENSE APPROACH TO ADDRESS
THIS PRESSING ISSUE FOR THE
STATE AT THIS CHALLENGING TIME.
FOR THESE REASONS WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY AND WE REALLY YOU FOR
YOUR TIME I'M ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER WEINBERG WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WERE
ACTUALLY GOING TO OUR SECOND
AND FINAL PRIMARY WITNESS.
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE HER
NAME IS MISS CISNEROS SHE'S
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL GOOD MORNING MRS
NEAREST YOU ARE NOW LIVE IN
COMMITTEE YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU A.
THIRTY SECOND PROP THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU CARE MCGUIRE AND THANK YOU
LEADERSHIP AND OFFERING
COMPLAIN MY DISPLAY. THAT HOW
CLOSE ARE AT THE TRAINING
RECALL I AM FORWARD WANT THEIR-
WE ARE NOT. PUBLIC POLICY OR
ANYTHING LED BY OVER THREE A OF
THE LARGE EMPLOYER ACROSS THE
NINE BAY AREA. WE ADDED
RESTAURANTS AND A BETTER OF
LIFE FOR EVERYONE WHO LIVES BUT
AT THE END FOR NO ADEQUATELY
LIFE HE TO DECLINE THAT. OF
YOUR HOUSE SHORTAGE FURTHER
DRIVE HOW THE. VERY HELPFUL
CONDUCTED ANNUAL. INSIDERS AND
IT AND THEN THE EARLY THAT THE
READER OUT YOUR PLATE. THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE CONCERN
BREAKING EVEN HIGHER THAN FOR
THE NIGHT. WHAT HOW COSTS IN
AVAILABLE. OUR POLL RESULTS
UNDERSCORE THE COULD BE A
CONTINUE THE BRA WITH THE HOW
RIGHT. AT THE COMPOUNDED THE
CURRENT PUBLIC RIGHT. HI OUR
MEN ARE TRY TO DOT THE FACT
CHANGING A CAR. UPGRADE FAMILY
THAT MEASURE THAT CLOSURES FOR
I THOUGHT TO TWELVE THOUSAND BY
THE END OF YEAR. FROM NINETEEN
HUNDRED LAST YEAR. YOU HAVE TO
SAY THAT YOUR FORGET MARTYR
ANYTHING THERE AND FURTHER GOT
BY IMPASSE AND- WELL AT THE
CORE SHIFT ON MY SHOW. IN
ADDITION THE NINETEEN HOW OFTEN
ABOUT BIRTH AND MA'AM THREE.
THEIR HELP THE FLESH TO WORK
FROM HOME QUALITY. FOR THE
REASON FOR THE DELAY IN AREA
ARE KEY AND WE RE SHE THE
FUTURE PRETTY. WHAT ABOUT
ECONOMY AND OUR MENU CHALLENGES
AND ENGAGE IN THE COMMERCIAL
REAL ESTATE INDUSTRY IN A NEW
WAY CALIFORNIA HOUSING SHORTAGE.
FOR THESE REASONS AND MORE
HELPFUL DRAWING OR GET YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AT THE BY. YEAR THANK
YOU SO MUCH MRS NEAR THREE PRE
SHEET YOUR TESTIMONY LADIES IN
GENERAL COMMITTEE WERE GONNA BE
STICKING WITH OUR TESTIMONY ON
THE PHONE LINES WE'RE NOW GOING
TO BE GOING TO OUR MODERATOR
MODERATORS CAN IT BE
ANNOUNCING. TO GET FOLKS
PREPARED IN THE QUEUE IN
SUPPORT IN SUPPORT NOW OF THE
S. P. THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
MISTER MODERATOR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR YES WE HAVE A MANY
PEOPLE QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO TO WINE FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING LINE FORTY TWO. ALRIGHT
NEXT CALLER PLEASE MR MODERATOR.
ONE ONE THIRTY EIGHT GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR THAT HOLLY FOR MANY THEY
HAD TO THAT LIFE HEALTH PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING IN FOR THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF A CLIENT
INCLUDING HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIAN BE THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLANNING
IN URBAN INSTITUTE ALSO KNOWN
AS FOR AS TO BE AT HOME AS WELL
AS CAN BE PARTNER ALL OF THE
PARK THANK YOUNG YOU SO MUCH
HOLLY IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE A
COMMON ON THIS BILL PLEASE DIAL
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE.
964-844-2916 THREE SIX FOUR
WITH THE CODE SIX TWO TWO SIX
FIVE FIVE EIGHT. HEARING FROM
YOU WERE LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO
WERE CURRENTLY IN SUPPORT. OF
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE MISTER
MODERATOR NEXT CALL PLEASE.
BLIND SEVENTY FOUR GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS ROBERT
NAYLOR REPRESENTING SHIELDS THE
THAN COMPANY A AN ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS- STRONG SUPPORTER OF
CALIFORNIAN BEEN A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS EFFORT TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF MAKING
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY. THANK YOU
MISTER NAYLOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE MR MODERN. LINE FORTY
FOUR GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING
GREG HERDER WITH CARPENTER
SIEVERS ON BEHALF OF SCHNEIDER
ELECTRIC NORTH AMERICAN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT CALLER MODERATOR. LINE ONE
FORTY FIVE GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING DEBORAH CARLTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER MISTER MODERATOR. LINE
ONE FORTY EIGHT GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ALEX TOWARDS THE
STRATEGY THREE SIXTY AND ON
BEHALF OF FOR GROWTH ACTUALLY
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
TORRES LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. BLIND ONE FORTY NINE
GOOD MORNING. HI GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IF I MAY NEED I'M HERE ON
THE HOT ONE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY CENTER OVERTHE
LAST FEW WEEKS WE HAVE
WITNESSED THAT WE NEED OF OUR
COMMUNITY DURING THIS TIME THAT
MAKE THAT IS GOING TO MAD. AND
FOR ANY GRAND FIND ALL THEY
WANT AND FONG NINE ACROSS A CRY.
I HAVE. WELL DONE WE ARE WHY OR
THINK THE NEXT. WE A RUN BRANCH.
AT THE FIRST HELP AVAILABLE TO
THE OUTBREAK MEETING AND I'M-
THAT AN EMPLOYEE CRIED WITH A
SINGLE. HUNDRED GRAND YOU. NOT
ACCEPTABLE I NEVER COMMUNITY
THAT THERE'S BETTER THAT IS WHY
STRONGLY SUPPORT. OF A WITH THE-
PLATE FIND DOCKING THEIR WORK I
HAVE BEEN IMPACT MICHAEL BUT-
IN THE GYM BUT- WE DON'T. WANT
TO GO OF IN MIDDLE THAT.
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER. HOLDER
AND CALIFORNIA ARE YOU SOME.
I'M YOUNG. TAX CREDIT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR VERY GRAY. WE
CURRENTLY IN SOME FOR SPEECH.
EIGHT FIVE. A MEAN TO INTERRUPT
THAT SINCE WE'VE HAD. OUR TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES WHO HAVE
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE. WE'RE
LOOKING FOR FOLKS IF YOU CAN
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME THE ORDER. IN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT. OF IT WE WILL.
EXIT IN BETWEEN. SURE THAT'S GO
OUR NEXT CALL PLEASE. NINE ONE
THIRTY NINE GOOD MORNING. IT
MORNING MARINO LINE HEALTH
HOUSING CONSORTIUM AWARE BEEN
WIENER WE CERTAINLY SOME THE
BILL CON AND HAVE FUN DOING IT
ON MY BILL AND THAT FAMILY JUST
HOPE TO ENSURE THE THAT YOU I
CALM AS THE- FORWARD. THANK YOU.
FOR COMMENTS. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE MODERATE. WHY EIGHT.
GOOD MORNING. THE MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE STILL FOR A
ON THE OF STATE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL THAT'S
GOOD OR NEXT CALLER IS
MODERATOR. LINE. ONE FORTY
THREE. AUDREY WOULD TIE CHECK
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTY THAT THAT THE ASIAN
AND THE COURT THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THAT TESTIMONY NEXT
CALLER PLEASE AS THE MODERATOR.
LINE SEVEN GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE GERMAN SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE LINK AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
WERE A BIT OF A TWEENER AS WELL
I COULD HAVE JUST A COUPLE
SECONDS I WANT TO SAY THAT WE
ARE SUPPORTERS AMENDED PETITION
PROVIDED WITH NINE WAY AGENTS
KILLED IN TRYING WORKFORCE
LANGUAGE DECEMBER. WHAT OUR
STATE UNTIL DOT. DEVELOPMENT BY
BRIGHT. AND NOW HAS TWENTY THE
COSTS LOW. ALL YOUR PREVIEW
BILLS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE SENATOR. AND
STAFF AS A BILL SORT THANK YOU.
THIS IS MADE WE APPRECIATE YOUR-
THANK YOU SOME. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER MISTER MODERATOR.
LINE FORTY. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING TODAY FANTASY OUT THE
BRIDGE HOUSING AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BLIND ONE FORTY TWO
GOOD MORNING. HEY GOOD MORNING
THIS IS SANDY GEORGIA'S EMERIC
IMPLYING SUBSTATION THAT WE
ALSO HAVE A SUPPORT AND THE
POSITION OF BEEN WORKING WITH-
DINNER COPY OUR STAFF WE
APPRECIATE THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO DO THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER MODERATOR HOW
MANY FOLKS WE HAVEN'T. YOU WE
HAVE FOUR MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SO MUCH THIS GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER MISTER MODERATOR YOU IN
A GREAT JOB TODAY SIR. THANK
YOU. LINE ONE FIFTEEN THE
MORNING. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN CAP CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA STATE SENSATION OF
COUNTY IN THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
THIS MORNING- WE NEED TO YOU
ARE A TWEENER WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE BUT WE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE GOAL OF
PROMOTING REDEVELOPMENT OF
COMMERCIAL CORRIDORS ESPECIALLY
THOSE EXISTING AND- EXTRA COM A
HIGHER DENSITY HOUSING. IN FACT
MANY ALREADY DO THAT THAT SAID
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED SOME
TECHNICAL ISSUES AND SHARE
THOSE WITH THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE
THAT WE HOPE TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS AS THE BILL FORWARD SO
THAT WE CAN INSURE SENSE OF-
TENTACLE AFFECT. THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND IT'S A BIT IN ON THE
AREAS THAT STATE WITH A
GREATEST NAY AND- HELPING GROW.
APPRECIATE THE SENATORS F. AND
WE FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH HER THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CONTENT PRECIADO ED
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE FORTY
SIX GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING
COREY SNAP ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
EIGHTY I THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MRS SMITH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE ONE FIFTY THREE
GOOD MORNING. A GOOD MORNING
THIS IS STEVE KERR'S ON THE
HOUSE YEP OF WESTFIELD IN
WORKSHOPS SUPPORT OF THEIR
TWENTY FIVE ANYTHING SENATOR
KIRBY ALSO IS IMPORTANT AND
EVEN MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER MISTER MODERATOR.
LINE ONE FIFTY GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS I THINK
I GOT THEIR GARCIA I AM A
CHIRLA MEMBER AND I WOULD LIKE-
I FOR BUDGETS ARE UNDOCUMENTED
FOR WHO ARE IN NEED OF WHO ARE
WORKERS WHO BECAME UNEMPLOYED
TO COLD IN NINETEEN THIS IS
THE- WHAT HAPPENED WITH MY
FAMILY- I AM CURRENTLY A
STUDENT ARE YOU THE SENATE
GROUP AND HAVE HAD TO TAKE UP.
A JOB OF THIRTY TWO HOURS- IN
ORDER TO HELP PROVIDE FOR THEM
AND SO I WOULD LIKE TO ASK FOR.
OUR MONEY FOR IT FOR THIS TO BE
POSSIBLE THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH. SO WE'RE GONNA WE HAVE
SOME FOLKS WHO ARE TALKING
ABOUT SOME BUDGET ALLOCATIONS.
IN THE QUEUE WE'LL GET THAT
SORTED OUT LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE DO A
LAST CALL FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT.
YES AND LADIES AND GENTLEMAN S.
ONE THEN ZERO TO QUEUE UP AT
THIS TIME PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR I JUST WANT TO DO SO
WERE IN ON THE SAME PAGE MISTER
MINER YOU MAY HAVE SOME
INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL BE CALLING
IN IN REGARDS TO BUDGET- IT
JUST IF YOU COULD LET THEM KNOW
pFINANCE COMMITTEE THAT WILL
HAVE THE SAME LINE DURING
BUDGET BUT MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU DON'T MIND JUST. DOING A
LITTLE BEHIND THE SCENES WORK
ON THAT THAT IS THE GOVERNMENT
FINANCE COMMITTEE AND BUDGET
WILL BE COMING UP LATER TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISSOURI
MODERATOR WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
A TURNING THE FLOOR OVER AT TWO
IN PERSON TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
WE LIKELY TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE AT THIS
TIME IN FORTY TWO OF THREE.
HEARING SEEN NINE WERE NOT
GONNA BE GOING TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY REMOTE VIDEO ROOM WE HAVE
NO ONE IN. ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE JUMPING BACK OVER
TO OUR PHONE LINES. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE HERE
TODAY. WE'RE GONNA BE TURNING
IT OVER. TO THE MODERATOR
MISTER MODERATOR. IF YOU CAN
PLEASE MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT
MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL. WHO
THAT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF
SP THIRTEEN B. FIVE. BUT IN
GERMAN TO SPEAK UP IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
BEEN ZERO AT THIS TIME TO PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. NINE FOLKS THAT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
YOU AND HERE'S OUR PHONE NUMBER
844-291-6364 YOU CAN DIAL THAT
AND THEN YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A
CODE THAT CODE WILL BE SIX TWO
TWO. SIX FIVE FIVE EIGHT CODE
AND PHONE NUMBER WE WANT TO
HEAR FROM YOU IS ON YOUR SCREEN
NOW FEEL FREE TO START DIALING
WE'RE LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION.
YEAH SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
ALL RIGHT MISTER MODERATOR THAT
SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE CUED UP
IN OPPOSITION OF THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE. ONE ONE FIFTY
FOUR. HI MY NAME IS CHARLIE
CARL THEM A RESEARCH ANALYST
FOR UNIQUE YOU. I WANT TO BE
CLEAR WE DON'T OPPOSE THE BILL
WERE MORE OF AN IN BETWEEN- OUR
UNION SUPPORTS INCREASING
HOUSING SUPPLY VERTICALLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO ADDRESS
OUR HOUSING CRISIS. WE
PARTICULARLY DO SUPPORT THE
CONVERSION OLD MALLS AND
OFFICES TO HOUSING BUT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THE BILL DOES NOT
UNINTENTIONALLY STREAMLINED
PROJECTS. WITH LARGE COMMERCIAL
COMPONENT OR STOP STOP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FROM INSISTING ON
GREATER RESIDENTIAL COMPONENT
NEEDS MARKET. BUT IN THESE
PROJECTS AND PROVIDE ASSURANCES
THESE IT UNITS FOR THE HOUSING
MARKET NOT THE SHORT TERM
RENTAL MARKET. IN PARTICULAR I
POINT OUT THAT UNDER THE
DEFINITION HOUSING DEVELOP
PROJECT IN CURRENT LAW TWO
THIRDS RESIDENTIAL BY SQUARE
FOOTAGE YOU CAN EVEN HAVE
PROJECTS THAT MORE HOTEL ROOMS.
AMPLE RESIDENTIALLY BECAUSE I
DON'T ANSWER JUST SMALLER.
GARCIA THIS BILL WE- THE
DEFINITION HOUSING. INSECTS TWO
LIMITS. IT WITH SOMEONE IN A
RETAILER OFFICE BUT WANT TO
CLARIFY BE CERTAIN THAT
DEFINITION REPLY IT ANY MORE
OLD OFFICE SPACE THAT IS
CONVERTED TO HOUSING PROJECT
WHERE YOU HAVE SB THIRTY FIVE
STREAMLINING WE SUBMITTED A
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AS A FACT
AND LOOK FORWARD TO. WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND OTHER
MEMBERS TO MAKE SURE BILL MOST
FOR WITH THESE IMPORTANT
CHANGES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR MONEY. MUCH FORMAL
OPPOSITION THAT IT THIRD PARTY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT WE'LL TAKE
THAT WE PREACH. AND THE
TESTIMONY FOR MEMBERS FROM
UNITE HERE WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO OUR PHONE LINES LAYS IN
GERMAN LET'S CHECK IN WITH THE
MODERATOR SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE. AS CHAIR
THERE IS NO WAY. BUT MR
MODERATOR CAN WE DO A LAST CALL
FOR OPPOSITION THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE. YES SIR- AND AGAIN
LEADERS IN GERMAN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. ANYONE
IN THE GAME AS MODERATOR. THERE
IS NOT ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR NOT GONNA BE BRINGING
IT BACK TO- HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE THE BILL RECEIVED
THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IN
ROOM FORTY TWO THREE TWO COULD
PLEASE STAND NOW HERREN SEEN ON
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE
PREFERRED TO SPEAK AGAINST THIS
BILL IN ROOM TWENTY FOUR. WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO CAN.
IN A SPEECH. EIGHT FIVE. THE
REASON GERMAN WILL TAKE A
MOTION OR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE. SOME
OF THE MOTION THAT MOTION IS BY
SENATOR TITLE DO WE SEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE HEARING SEE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. BETTER
SENATOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS FOR
CLOSING COMMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR FOR- A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
TO HEAR FROM THE WITNESSES AND
ALSO- 2% I'M I'M BUYING WAS
REMISS IN NOT THINKING THE-
SENATE PRO TEMP- ATKINS FOR
INCLUDING THIS BILL AS PART OF
THE SENATE- HOUSING PRODUCTION
PACKAGE AND SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE BOOK TODAY.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH IS
CENTER COME HERE AGAIN JUST
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AT. FOR HER AMAZING
WORK ON THIS BILL THERE'S A
LONG. YOU YEARS. APPROACH HAVE
TELL SOLOMON IS YOU SO MUCH.
BRING THIS OUR I THE MOTION A
DO PASSED APPROPRIATE VICE
TYLER MR NOW CAN CALL THE-
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI WATER HI
MORE WALK. WILLOW ALL RIGHT
SENATOR BILL. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR HURTADO HI RICARDO HI
SENATOR NIELSEN WILSON HI
SENATOR WIENER WIENER ON THIRTY
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO
FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT'S
BIPARTISAN LOVE RIGHT THERE I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE VERY GRATEFUL CENTER
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS COME
HERE FOR ALL YOUR WORK FOR AND
KEEP THAT BILL ON CALL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GEN MANY NOW CAN
WE GOING FOR A- I OF THE DAY
YOU WERE ARE GOING TO INVITE
THE DEAN OF THE SENATE CENTER
NIELSEN TO BE AT A PRESENT ON
SB NINE FIFTY TWO. BUT LOOK
CENTER THING HAPPENED SO
INCREDIBLY HARD HIS DISTRICT
HAS BEEN HIT SO INCREDIBLY HARD.
OUR OFF. BY FIRE BUT THIS IS
CRITICAL BILL WE'RE GONNA TURN
THE FLORIDA CENTER NIELSEN IN.
BUSINESS AND I WANT TO ENSURE
THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE TAKING.
THE AN IMMENSE AS PRESENTED THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES.
INDEED I WILL BE DELIGHTED TO
ACCEPT. COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
ALL DOCTORS AS OFTEN AS MEN
THAT SUIT FOR CHAIR. WE'VE HAD
LAST YEAR HAD SOME AN
INTERESTING YEAR TO SAY THE
LEAST. BUT HAS OF WHAT. THE
EVOLVED I WANTED TO SAY. THE
VAULT BUT LET PUBLIC POWER IN A
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS.
WERE EMPLOYED. NOW SURELY WHO
HOPE THAT THIS DOES NOT BECOME
THE NEW NORM. AS A STRATEGY FOR
DEALING WITH THESE KIND OF
CRISES IT'S VERY WRONG WAY IN
FACT TO DEAL WITH THE- BUT WHAT
DID THEN DEVELOPED FOR A WHOLE
LOT OF REASONS AND I'M NOT
GETTING INTO A COMPLAINT
SESSION ABOUT ALL OF THOSE
REASONS. BUT THERE WAS A DELUGE
I THINK IN MOST OF OUR OFFICES.
OF INDIVIDUALS. COMPLAINING
ABOUT THIS PUBLIC POWER SHUT
OFF AND THAT THEY DIDN'T KNOW
AND THE TIMING WAS TOO SHORT TO
DO ANY GOOD FOR TO RENDER
PREPARE THEMSELVES ETCETERA
ETCETERA. AT THAT THAT READY
WAS IT WAS A DILEMMA FOR US
LAST YEAR. THIS BILL INTENT THE
END IS TO ANOTHER TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX. PARTICULARLY FOR SOME
OF OUR AGENCIES. THIS WOULD
ALLOW THEN THAT ON SUCH
OCCASIONS OF THE PUBLIC POWER
SHUT OFF. WHENEVER THAT THAN IT
DID OCCUR. THERE WE THE
OPPORTUNITY. FOR THE LOCAL
PUBLIC AGENCIES. TO RECEIVE
SOME ASSISTANCE HERE. TO BE
ABLE TO NEGOTIATE AND WHAT
WOULD I DO PROVIDING BACKUP
GENERATORS THEY BECAME VERY
MUCH IN DEMAND EVERYWHERE LAST
YEAR BACK A BACKUP GENERATORS.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THEN
THESE ENTITIES. TO PURCHASE
BACKUP GENERATORS BUT AN
INCENTIVE. WOULD BE THE
EQUIPMENT AND SERVICE SEVEN AND
A HALF PERCENT SALES TAX WITH A
WOULD BE EXEMPTED FROM THAT
SALES TAX AS AN INCENTIVE TO IF
YOU WILL POWER UP TO HAVE BACK
UP GENERATIONS KEEPING
NECESSARY SERVICES GOING. DO
YOU HAVE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
MORE CLEARLY STATE AND CODIFY
THE STANDARD FOR BACK UP
GENERATIONS. DEFINES CRITICAL
FUNCTIONS WHICH WOULD TRIGGER
AND SUPPORT SUCH A BACKUP IN
THE EMPLOYING SUCH BACKUP
GENERATION. THAT THE GENERATION
WOULD BE STRICTLY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF POWER GENERATION.
DURING THE SHUTDOWN. IN A FIVE
YEAR SUNSET AND A REPORT. TO
THE LEDGE OF LEGISLATIVE-ANALYST'S OFFICE AS TO HOW THIS
WAS GOING ALONG. I'M. JANET NOT
REALLY ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THESE
KINDS OF THINGS BUT THIS IS
SUCH A CRITICAL. SITUATION FOR
OUR CONSTITUENTS FOR THE PEOPLE
THERE IN CONVENIENCE. IN A DAY
THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY. SO
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES
WHAT MY DESIRE HERE IS TO ALLOW
ANOTHER TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX. TO
BE ABLE TO IMPAIR OR THESE
AGENCIES TO HAVE A BIT OF AN
INCENTIVE AND YOU KNOW WE ALL
KNOW HOW TROUBLED THEY ARE. A
TO GET THESE BACK UP GENERATORS
IN PLACE. AND TO SOFTEN. THE
IMPACT. OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFFS. THAT IS THE
BILL MISTER CHAIRMAN HYDE
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. TO CENTER
NIELSEN FOR HIS WORK ON THIS
ISSUE LOOK THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THIS SEVEN YEARS IN HIS FOCUS
ON THE HARDEST COMMUNITY WITH
THIS. IN ITS FIRST ONE COMES TO
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE WHETHER
IT'S HOSPITALS OR POLICE OR
FIRE STATIONS. SEWER AND OR
WATER PLANTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK ON THE CENTER NIELSEN
GREATLY APPRECIATED. WE'RE
GONNA TAKE THREE FORMS OF
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY FIRST THE
PHONE SECOND FORTY TWO THREE
THIRTY IS GOING TO BE TWENTY
FORTY.LET'S ASK OUR MODERATOR
DEPLETES TO THE MIND TO THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
NINE FIVE TWO TWO MODERATOR. AS
CHAIR. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO IF YOU LIKE TO BE
ADDED TO DISSIPATE IN THIS
CONVERSATION WE WELCOME YOU.
844-291-6364 IS THE NUMBER TO
CALL YOUR INTO THE CODE SIX TWO
TWO SIX FIVE FIVE EIGHT. PLEASE
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN NOW YOU GOT
THE PHONE NUMBER YOU GOT THE
CODE ON THERE WE WELCOME YOUR
TESTIMONY LET'S GO BACK TO THE
MODERATOR MISTER MODERATOR YEAH
THE ANYONE IN SUPPORT SB EIGHT
NINE FIVE TWO. ON THE PHONE. WE
DO MISTER CHAIR. WE'RE GONNA GO
TO LINE THIRTY FIVE GOOD
MORNING. HI THIS IS JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
OUR THIRTY SEVEN WORLD COUNTIES
FOR THE BRANCH OF LAST YEAR'S
PS PS OF HANDS AND SO WERE
KEENLY INTERESTED AND MEASURES
THAT HELP IMPROVE LOCAL ENERGY
RESILIENCE AS AS THE NINE FIFTY
TO SIXTY TWO. MANY OF OUR
COUNTIES EXPERIENCE FIBER MORE
PSP US IN ON SOME TWENTY
NINETEEN WITH SOME COUNTIES
NEVER HAPPENED OUR FULLY
RESTORED BEFORE THE NEXT SET UP
WHICH TRIGGERED. YEAH YOU'RE
THE CONTINUED OPERATION OF BIO
CRITICAL DISORDERS YOUNG FOR
STRUCTURE NECESSARY TO MAINTAIN.
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY JAILED
PART WE- MUNICH. OF AND WHAT
SYSTEMS TO NAME A FEW. WOMAN OF
THESE FACILITIES ALREADY HAD
BACK GENERATORS ON SITE SOME
SMALLER FACILITIES COULD NOT
YOU HAD DIFFICULTY SECURING
GENERATION TO MAINTAIN
OPERATIONS. OTHER FACILITIES
HAVE THE BACKUP GENERATORS FAIL
WHEN NEEDED THEREBY MESSAGE
THAT SUFFOCATING COSTLY
REPLACEMENT. SB NINE FIFTY TO
HELP TO REDUCE THE COSTS FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PROCURE BACK
UP ELECTRICAL RESOURCES FROM
THE- COLD THE SOLUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS WILL HELP
WILL. BE MOSTLY OPERATE THIS
SYSTEM BETTER. ACTING PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY. ALWAYS TRY
SUPPORT SB NINE TWO WE LOOK FOR
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR THIS
COMMITTEE TO RESOLVE SOME
LINGERING ISSUES THE MAI TAI
LOCALS HANDS USING GENERATORS.
SENSE CRITICAL SO IT IS BACK UP
GENERATION IS TYPICALLY
INTENDED TO CRIED POWER DURING
ANY LOSS OF ELECTRICITY WHETHER
DUE TO REGULAR UTILITY SYSTEM
MAINTENANCE DISASTER OR PS PS
AMOUNT. WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORED BRING THIS BILL BOARD
ENTERED YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE APPRECIATE THAT
MISTER KENNEDY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY LETTUCE IN
GENERAL COMMITTEE LET'S KEEP ON
THE PHONE LINES RIGHT NOW
MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE OUT SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
OF SB NINE FIVE TWO. WE DO
MISTER CHAIR. LINE ONE SIXTY
TWO GOOD MORNING. LET'S CHECK
IN AGAIN NINE SIXTY TWO GOOD
MORNING YOUR LIVE IN COMMITTEE.
MISTER MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. PINE
SIXTY NINE GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT CALLER
PLEASE MR MODERATOR. LINE
TWENTY THREE GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JULIE A HALL
AND WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WERE
ACTUALLY AT THE PORTENT HAN
PETITION ON THE BILL I'M ONLY
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR EFFORTS
ON THAT ISSUE I WOULD THINK
LIMITING THE USE OF ADDITIONAL
BACKUP ELECTRIC POWER FOR
EXCLUSIVE USE OF THE ENERGY
STATION EVENT THE TO LIMITING-
ECHOING WHAT JOHN KENNEDY
SHARED EQUIPMENT THAT OUR
MEMBERS PROJECT FOR THE BACK OF
PURPOSES IT'S FOR A NUMBER OF
EMERGENCY TYPE EVENT THANK THAT
THEY'RE MAKING THESE. BUT IT
WOULD MAKE IT. IT'S REALLY NOT
AS YOUR- AND NEEDED BASED ON
THE FACT RECOMMENDATION. FOR
CLARIFYING CHANGES WHILE WE
HAVEN'T THE IN THE AMENDMENTS
WE WOULD JUST ASK THAT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CLARIFIED WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT FEDERAL DISTRICT
CONTINUE TO BE ELIGIBLE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH YES LOOK
AT THE BOTTOM LINE IN THIS IT
REGIS REQUIRES. IT EXCLUSIVELY
TO USE OF THE BACKUP GENERATOR
JASON INDIAN ENERGIZING EVENT
BUT- AB I'M I KNOW THAT THE
CENTER WILL BE WORKING WITH YOU
ON THAT ISSUE. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE
SIXTY ONE GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
IDEA GREATER DASH BUT THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY IN
THE PARK. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MODERATOR HOW MANY FOLKS WITH
THE Q. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT LET'S DO OUR LAST CALL
MISTER MODERATOR FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT FOR NINE FIVE TWO.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. PRESS ONE
AND ZERO. HOW WE LOOKING TO
MODERATOR. THERE IS NO ONE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS THE
MODERATOR WERE NOT AN ATTORNEY
HERE INTO THE ROOM THE FORTY
TWO OR THREE ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE DON'T
RUSH TO THE MICROPHONE ALL AT
ONCE THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FIFTY TWO WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO
TO A REMOTE HEARING ROOM. ANY
FORTY IN THE START ST CRICKETS
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
OUR PHONE LINES WE'RE GONNA
LOOK TO OUR PHONE LINES WERE TO
GO BACK TO THE MODERATOR MISTER
MODERATOR WE'RE LOOKING FOR
THOSE NOW IN OPPOSITION
OPPOSITION OF SB. NINE FIVE
TWO. CAN YOU PLEASE MAKE THE
ALL CALL. THESE IN GERMAN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. PRESS ONE NINE ZERO
WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
YOU TODAY PLEASE DIAL EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. THAT NUMBER IS
GONNA BE ON YOUR SCREEN
SHORTLY. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
PLEASE ENTER PLEASE ENTER THE
CODE ON YOUR SCREEN. MISTER
MODERATOR. TO HAVE ANY FOLLOW
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE. IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. NINE SEVEN
NINE FIFTY TWO. THERE IS NO
ONE. ALL RIGHT IT'S TWO ONE
LAST CALL AND WILL BRING IT
BACK AT TWO FORTY TWO THREE
LAST CALL PLEASE MR MODERATOR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE TWO ZERO PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO. SO GIVE IT A QUICK
MOMENT. IT'S A MODERATOR ANYONE
IN THE QUEUE. MISTER CHAIR
THERE IS NO ONE THANK YOU SO
MUCH GREAT JOB TODAY MISTER
MODERATOR WE COULD NOT HAVE
DONE IT WITHOUT YOU SO JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR WORK AND AGAIN PLEASE STAY
SAFE. MODERATORS COMING TO US
FROM THE ATHLETES TODAY SO
WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE AND HIS
HARD WORK WE'RE GONNA LOOK TO
ROOM FORTY TWO OF THREE TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. HERE AND SEE NO ONE
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO ROOM
TWO. FORTY TWENTY FOUR BE A
THERE IS NO ONE EITHER LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. DO
YOU HAVEANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OF PLEASE MISTER VICE CHAIR AND
MORE ALSO WELCOME THE MOTION AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
MISTER CHURCHES- FOUR ONE.
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR. USUALLY
I HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME WHEN
SACRAMENTO GIVES A SALES TAX
BREAK. ON PRODUCTS WHICH MEANS
THAT THE LOCAL MUNICIPALITY
CITY YOUR COUNTY WILL REALLY
LOSE OUT ON. THE SALES TAX
REVENUES I DON'T SEEM TO SEE IT
OPPOSITION FROM THE CITIES. OR
COUNTIES TO YOUR BILL- SO I
GUESS I COULD. MODIFY MY
APPROACH BUT I'M WONDERING
INSTEAD OF. GIVING A SALES TAX
BREAK WHICH MEANS THE LOCAL
MUNICIPALITY WOULD LOSE A
PORTION OF THE REVENUES WHY NOT
HAVE THE STATE JUST GIVE- A
REBATE FOR THE SALES TAX
PORTION IT RECEIVES. SIR
NIELSEN WELL IF THE FEDERAL
THAT THAT COULD BE A
CONSIDERATION BUT- IF MARKETS
AND DINNER BRACING FOR THIS
WHAT MY FOCUS ON WAS THE- A
PERILOUS JEOPARDY THAT WE ARE.
AGENCIES THAT DO NEED TO
RESPOND AND BE TIMELY THE HOW
COULD WE BEST THE DIRECT MOST
DIRECTLY HELP THEM. AND INDEED
I'M GLAD THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE NOT FELT THAT THIS WAS A
HUGE PROBLEM RATHER MAYBE
LOOKING AT INTO THE HELP TO
THEM BECAUSE THEY RECEIVED I'M
SURE QUITE A FEW OF THESE CALLS
AS WELL. BUT IT DIDN'T I
WOULDN'T FOCUSING ON THE STATE
RESOURCES OR FROM THE STATE
BUDGET OF. FOR OBVIOUS REASONS
WE'RE WE'RE AND PERILOUS TIMES
AND I DON'T THINK WE CAN BE
ASKING MORE HELP TO YOU KNOW TO
BE A SPECIAL LEGISLATION FOR
THE ACQUISITION OF THESE
GENERATORS AND SO THE SALES TAX
SEEM TO BE THE MOST EXPEDITIOUS
AND DIRECT APPROACH TO ME. IN A-
I BE ENTERTAINING BEATLES
THOUGHTS ABOUT IT THAT I. I
HAVEN'T FOCUSED ON THAT AT ALL
AND I'D BE WILLING TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SENATOR
ON THIS MATTER MAYBE THERE'S A
WAY WE COULD TO CUT SO AMENDED
LIKE I JUST DON'T REALLY SEE IT
THE MOST PRACTICAL. OF THAT IS
THE MOST PRACTICAL MEANS AT
THIS POINT THE LIVE LET'S TALK
ABOUT. THANK YOU SENATOR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS VICE CHAIR LAYS IN
GENERAL COMMITTEE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS CONVERSATIONS
QUESTIONS OUR CONVERSATION. IS
THERE A MOTION TO APPROVE. WE
HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR HER TITLE IT'S DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AT THE SENATE
OVER THE DINNER SENATE FOR
CLOSING COMMENTS PLEASE. WELL
AGAIN I THANK ALL WHO CALLED IN
AND THOSE OF YOU WHO DID AND
WANT MAYBE SOME FINE TUNING
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A LONG WAYS
TO GO WITH THE LEGISLATION AND
WE WOULD ENTERTAIN YOUR
THOUGHTS AND IDEAS AS WELL AS
CERTAINLY TALK TO THE VICE
CHAIRMAN AS WE POCEED. AGAIN
UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE REALLY
DOING SOMETHING JUST TO SOFTEN
THE BILL BUT ALSO IS THIS NOT
JUST TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
OR GOT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AUTHORITIES. WATER AGENCIES
ETCETERA BUT IT'S TO THE THIS
THE CITIZENS THAT WE REPRESENT
THAT ARE IMPACTED BY THE SHUT
OFF AND THE DISRUPTION OF THEIR
LIVES AND THE BACKUP GENERATORS
AT LEAST SOFTENS THE IMPACT
THAT IS TO MERIT TO THE BILL
AND I WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IN THANK YOU SO MUCH. YES AND
YOUR WORK SIR ALL RIGHT AGAIN
THE MOST IS PASSES PURPOSE BY
TO MR NOW THE CALL THE ROLL.
AND THE RUMOR HI- SENATOR MORAL
ARC. BY LUCK HI SENATOR BILL I
WILL HI SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR HER TADO I RICARDO HI
SENATOR NIELSEN HI NIELSEN HI
SENATOR WIENER. WIENER HI SIX A
SIX ZERO SIX ZERO VOTE THAT
BILL IS GOING TO BE HELD FOR A
MOMENT TO EVER AND HOLD IT OPEN
AND ALLOW THE MAJORITY LEADER
TO ADD ON LAYS IN GENERAL WE'RE
GOING TO ASK EVERYONE TO PLEASE
HOLD FOR TWO MINUTES WE'RE
GOING TO DO A QUICK A
RECONCILIATION OF THE BUSINESS
AND THEN WE'LL LET YOU GO HERE
AND DO SOME ADD ONS IF YOU CAN
JUST PLEASE HOLD FOR TWO
MINUTES WE'RE GOING TO WORK ON
OUR PAPERWORK AND MAKING SURE
THAT EVERYBODY IS ON EACH BILL.
THANK YOU REALLY NICE JOB TODAY
ALL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WHAT DO
WE DO THIS LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE
JUST GOING TO WAIT TO FOR
CONFIRMATION. FROM THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S OFFICE BUT- TWO OTHER
FOLKS DON'T HAVE TO WAIT HERE
AT THE MOMENT- WE'RE GOOD TO GO
SENATOR HURTADO YOUR GOOD
YOU'RE CAUGHT UP ON- ON VOTES
NICE JOB TODAY CENTER TITLE.
CENTER TITLE WE NEED TO GIVE
CENTER WIENER- THE WORD NEXT
WEEK. NEXT WEEK SO WE CAN'T
FORGET ABOUT THAT- AND MAYBE TO
FOR. OKAY THAT SOUNDS GOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN CENTER
TYLER THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING
TODAY. LET'S ADD SENATOR BELL
ON THIS CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON ITEM NUMBER SIX ITEM NUMBER
SIX WHICH IS SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE. THE MOTION IS DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MR NOW. SENATOR
BELL. BILL BY SENATOR HERTZBERG.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT
DEL OPEN CIRCLE NOW DO WE NEED
TO HAVE MISTER BELL ON SB
THIRTEEN HUNDRED AS WELL WE
HAVE ONE MORE FOR YOU MISTER
BELL. WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS SB
THIRTEEN HUNDRED THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS
MR NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SENATOR MORLOCK.
SENATOR BELL. BILL HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG. WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THAT BILL OPEN FOR THE MOMENT
WILL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU.
ALRIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE
ARE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLE ONE MORE TIME. MR NOW CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB NINE FIVE
TWO THIS IS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED MOTION TO
APPROPRIATIONS MR NOW. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. ALL RIGHT LAYS IN
GERMAN THE FINAL VOTE IS SIX
ZERO SIX ZERO ON ITEM NUMBER
ONE THAT DEAL IS OUR CLOTHES IN
THE ROOM. WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SP THIRTEEN HUNDRED THE MOTION
IS TO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
MISTER NOW. SENATOR MORLOCK.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. IN GERMAN
THE FINAL VOTE ON SB THIRTEEN
HUNDRED ITEM NUMBER FIVE IS
FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO WE'RE
CLOSING THE ROLE. FINALIZING
FOR THE DAY ITEM SIX SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE THIS
MOTION IS DO PASTOR
PERFORATIONS MISTER NOW.
HERTZBERG PLEASE ENTER ON THE
COMMITTEE WE ARE NOW GOING TO
CLOSE THE ROLL CALL THE ROLL
AND THIS BILL IS OUT SIX ZERO
THE BILLS OUT SIX ZERO. AGAIN
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE LDC THE LDC IS WORKING AT A
EACH AND EVERY DAY AND LIVING
THE DREAM THAT WE TELL YOU HOW
ON ALL ISSUES SO WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH SURE
SERGEANTS TO NIKOLINA TO MISTER
NOW WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
ALL THE WORK WE'LL SEE YOU BACK
HERE. NEXT WEDNESDAY NEXT
WEDNESDAY FOR A ONE AND A HALF%
BILL HEARING IF YOU WILL. FOR
RECONSIDERATION WASABI HEARING
A SENATOR THE BILL WE ARE NOW
GOING TO GERMANY THANK YOU ALL.